in this course you will learn how to
design and use databases you will create
a graphical Windows application that can
display and modify data from a mySQL
database server Chad slooter is your
instructor for this course he is a
professor of computer science and
software development at Grand Canyon
University
in this video I'm going to show you how
to create this application that's on the
screen this will be a visual studio
project and we are going to focus in on
working with databases so let's look at
the features of what we're going to
build and then I'm going to give you the
outline of the different subjects that
we're going to cover some of the
technical things that you'll learn and
then finally we'll get into the part
where we start building it so let's look
at the features first and then we'll get
into what we actually have to learn so
in the features you can see on the
application that we have a database so
that's the main feature and we are going
to have a bunch of songs so you can see
that I have albums on the top table here
and when I click on an album
I have a preview of the album cover and
then in the bottom part we can see the
different songs that are on that album
so for instance here we got help and I
have a video player over here
and so we can listen to The Beatles
as they call for help
so if I choose the other song here
you'll see that it'll automatically
switch oh it looks to me like that one's
unavailable and then we get ticket to
ride and I have to suffer through and
add so this is just a YouTube player it
is not anything saved to my computer
alright so now I'm getting Ticket to
Ride like I asked for to begin with now
I can also delete some of these things
so for instance if I wanted for some
reason to get rid of Abby Road I can try
the delete button up here and then I get
a confirmed message that says are you
sure you want to delete number three as
you can see album number three is listed
here and I don't actually want to delete
this right now okay so now let's talk
about what are some of the features and
some of the programming that you're
going to learn first of all you can see
that we're going to build a database
let's see what this database looks like
you can see I have a table here called
album another one called track and I've
filled in some data for you we're going
to be working with mySQL and this tool
called MySQL workbench and so you can
see that the table definition here shows
that we have a foreign key relationship
between the album and all of the tracks
that are on that album so I will take
you through the process of setting up a
database and defining the different
fields and then creating this link
between the two tables called a foreign
key so this video is targeted at people
who know some programming but are not
really familiar with databases to a
great deal and so what we're going to do
is focus in on how to build this
database and to write the queries that
can make this application work my name
is shad sluter and I teach software
development at Grand Canyon University
in Phoenix Arizona so in this course
you're going to see the emphasis on
working with databases so I'm teaching a
course on SQL and on right now and
so you get to see the benefit of what
we're doing in class if you would like
to look at the full series of this thing
you can either subscribe to the channel
that you're looking at now on YouTube or
you can see the more extensive version
on studycoding.org which is another
website so I welcome you to come back
because people that are in my classroom
are becoming professional software
developers and getting great jobs and so
you could do that too okay so let's get
into the first phase of this so phase
number one is build the database phase
number two is to build the application
and then phase three is to connect those
two things together so we're starting
off here at the beginning which could
take a little while we're going to build
a database so what we're going to do
first is design the album table and then
after we have the album table working we
will go and try to make it connect to
the application and then we'll come back
to the track and we'll add the song
tracks later so we're going to build
this application kind of piecewise so
we'll get very basic to start with and
then more advanced as we get through the
series of videos so let's start with
building a new database okay so let's
get started with the tools that we're
going to need so in this first part
we're going to need to have a SQL Server
so there are various types of SQL
databases that you can install we're
going going to be using MySQL which is
free it's open source it runs on
multiple platforms however there are
other Alternatives besides MySQL even
though it's the most popular and widely
used database probably in the planet you
could use postgres which apparently has
more features you could use Microsoft
SQL which is a very scalable and is used
by a lot of Enterprise customers you
could go to Oracle they have a very
expensive system and you could probably
find others as well but my sequel is
what we're choosing because it has great
tools and it's free so the tool that
we're going to be using is mamp mamp
that stands for Macintosh
Apache
MySQL and PHP
now don't let the Macintosh part uh
scare you away because if we were to go
look at the downloads we're going to see
that the first version that they
recommend is for Windows so they have a
Windows version and a Mac version which
is really good because in my classroom I
have students that have both types of
operating systems on their computer so
we're going to install map and we're
going to wait for the download to finish
and then when we set it up we will not
choose map Pro but we will just use the
free version it will work just great for
our purposes
another tool that we'll be using in this
project is my SQL workbench and you can
see the download page here now MySQL
workbench is used for arranging more
complex databases and so we won't see
this for the first part of the tutorial
because we're only going to have a
single table to get started with but
just to let you know that this is coming
we will be using this eventually
to create the application that will make
this media player work we're going to be
using visual studio version 2022 and
we'll be creating a Windows desktop
application so we'll get to that part
when we get to the application we're
first of all going to build the database
though okay so now I have skipped ahead
I have installed map I have chosen not
to use mamp Pro so I unchecked one of
those boxes and now I have this
application up and running now I want to
start this so I'm going to click Start
servers and you're going to see two
different little green dots up here one
for Apache and the second one for MySQL
server now we could care less about
Apache server for this application this
is for hosting websites and this is not
going to be a web application however
we're going to be using a SQL Server so
that way we have the ability to handle
the database and so that's why I
installed map now there are other
packages that you could use if this
doesn't work out for you you could use
wamp WM MP which is for Windows you
could use zamp xamp you can search for
that it has the same functionalities
with different menus in different places
another tool which is really good that
is not required you to install anything
is the USB web server so the second link
on the page here actually has a free
version of what USB web server is and
you can download this and you can
literally run it from a USB stick you
could run it on any computer lab or you
don't have access to install software
and it will do the same features as what
we're going to do in the video so take
your pick I'm going to be using mamp and
that's what the tutorials will be
easiest to follow with so go ahead and
pick map if you can otherwise choose one
of the Alternatives okay so now we're
back now that we got the application
running let's go ahead and choose this
button called Open start page and you're
going to see that the website opens to
localhost slash map so let's go to tools
and I want to choose PHP my admin and
this will will bring up all of the
databases that I have installed on This
Server so you can see over on the left
side I have music MySQL and a few other
things so the only thing that we're
going to focus in on here is this one
called music and since that I've already
created this application I have some
data in it you can skip ahead if you
know how to do all of this we need to
create a table and fill it with some
data but I'm going to do that right now
so you can see the process the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
create a new database so I have music
I'm going to create a new one so let's
click the link at the top and this one
I'm just going to call it music 2
because I'm going to recreate the same
application the language that you choose
of course is probably English if you're
watching this video I'm just going to
choose the general text that we have
here now we are supposed to create a
table and the first table we're going to
create is called albums and now we have
to decide how many columns we're going
to put in the albums table okay so now
I'm going to cheat and I'm going to look
back to what I actually created in this
application so here's the other tab you
can see I'm going to create one two
three four five six six columns and I'm
going to have different data types in
each column so let's change this number
to a six and then choose create table
let's click the Go Button
the first thing we're going to do is
name the six columns so just going
straight down the left side of the form
I'm going to type in ID and a database
ID is always the first item it's a
number that has a unique identifier for
each record the next thing we're going
to put in is the album title and I'm
using an underscore to separate the
words you don't have to use underscores
but it's a pattern that a lot of people
use I'm going to use artist Year image
name and description to be the rest of
these so these were going to be the six
columns that describe each album in our
database now let's take a look at the
next item here so the type so every one
of these right now says int which stands
for integer now integers are numbers of
course now if I want to have something
besides an integer I can just select it
from here I'm going to choose a text
version so
varchar and text are two choices let's
take a look at the hints to see why we
would pick one or the other so varchar
is a variable length character string
and it is used for things like words or
titles so it fits perfectly with the
album title and then the next item over
here we can say how many characters so
let's say 100 letters is the length of
our title
now for the rest of these we're going to
add some more details so for the artist
this would also make sense to use a
variable character length varchar we've
got a year which will leave right at
integer that's easy to work with we
could pick date
but year is pretty simple to work with
we're going to work with an image name
which is a URL so it's the uh it's the
HTTP slash Wikipedia address that we're
going to get images from and so this
could be pretty long let's leave it at
let's say a thousand characters for the
maximum length then for the description
let's change this to text now the
difference between text and varchar is
kind of subtle so text is usually used
if you have a large section like a a
text area on a web page where you expect
to see paragraphs of information varchar
usually is a single line for like a a
name or an address or something rather
short so both of them are saving letters
in in a format that looks the same to us
but they are different in the computer's
mind so text works well for description
okay so this thing's ready to go so down
here at the bottom you can see that
there's a save button let's click it and
cross our fingers so as soon as I click
save you can see now I I have switched
to the tab called structure so structure
tells me what my database is made of so
you can see that we have all of these
data types that we just created and
there's going to be no data so if I
choose browse we're going to see that
the column headers are here here and
there's actually no data in the database
yet I'm going to change one item that I
forgot to do previously the first item
is an ID number and that is supposed to
be a unique number that the computer
generates so I'm going to click the
change icon and let's see why I would
want to change that
so I'm going to switch over here to this
item that says Auto increment a
underscore I that is not artificial
intelligence that's Auto increment and
when I select it it's going to
automatically choose the next number
available for whatever record I put in
so the first one will be at record
number one and then two and then so on
it never deletes uh or goes backwards so
it'll go to Infinity eventually but we
just want to make sure it's Unique so
let's say let's click save now as soon
as I click save you notice there's a new
icon here it's got a little key so that
tells me that the ID is now a primary
key which is important it means that it
is the only item really that has to be
filled in in all six columns and it will
be used to connect to this table to
other tables later on so that's enough
to get us started with our database
let's add some data
so as I try to add data I click on the
insert Tab and now I'm going to fill in
some items I'm going to leave the ID
blank because the computer is going to
automatically provide the next number in
the database so the first one will be
one
so we'll leave it blank the title for
our album is Abbey Road and it's done by
The Beatles and the date is 1961.
now let's see if we can get some
information from the internet to fill in
the other items so I've got a
description and an image URL let's just
use our friends at Wikipedia to help us
out so I'm going to search in Google for
Wikipedia and Abbey Road and let's bring
up the article that tells us about Abby
Road
so first of all the image let's take a
copy of that so I'm going to right click
it and choose copy image address and
let's switch back into our database and
now let's paste it here so let's see
control V and you can see that the URL
to this image is from uploads at
Wikipedia so I don't have to save this
to my disk I'm just going to rely on
whatever is hosted at Wikipedia so if
they delete this picture from their
website my application will no longer be
able to show the image so it saves me
space but then I have to rely on them
not to delete my image let's scroll down
a little bit and you can see the last
item here is a text field and we're
supposed to add a description well
here's a nice description let's just
copy the first part of the Wikipedia
article and let's paste it into our
database and now I don't have to type
anything now I'm going to click go
so it says here at the top that one row
has been inserted and it tells me the
SQL statement that was just executed you
notice it says insert into has the table
name then it mentions all of the column
names here and then the next statement
is values and then below that you can
see all of the text so if I click on
browse I should be able to go back and
see that now I have one item called
Abbey Road if I want to see one of these
in detail I can just double click it and
you can now see that I have a whole
bunch of data in the description which
takes multiple lines so that is how you
can fill in a table if you would like to
look at the full series of this thing
you can either subscribe to the channel
that you're looking at now on YouTube or
you can see the more extensive version
on studycoding.org which is another
website so here's your homework I want
you to fill in about a half a dozen
different albums so I'm picking the
Beatles you can choose any one you like
but we need to have something that we
can search for so for the next video I'm
going to show you how to query data and
you can search for certain keywords or
filter it so come back again and we'll
continue on our database application
hi in this second video of a series
we're going to continue to explore
building a SQL database application
here's the index of all of the things
we're going to learn in the first video
we worked through creating our first
database in this video we're going to
start to write some queries using the
SQL language in the future we're going
to talk about the front end connecting
our database to that front end doing
some searches inserting records creating
foreign Keys joining tables together
creating what's called uml diagrams
making compound queries or multiple
queries in one step we're going to
delete items from the database and then
finally at the very end of this course
we're talking about features that we
didn't get to but you could probably
explore so this whole series here is
available not only here where you're
watching but also on studycoding.org
which is my channel where I create
applications my name is shad sluter and
I welcome you to come to class class
with me virtually even where you can
become a professional software developer
so this course that we're covering right
now is focusing on databases but as you
can see from the selections on
studycoding.org that you can learn
c-sharp programming for websites or Java
or node.js and JavaScript and other
languages so many of my students have
become professional software developers
and have great jobs and I'd like the
same thing to happen for you so come
along and join us in class and plan your
future so just as a reminder where we're
going with this application this is the
final product and as you can see we have
a list of albums at the top of the page
and then we have a list of music or
tracks at the bottom and then a YouTube
player so that we can hear the music so
in the past video we created the
database that goes behind this top
control which is a grid and we're going
to work on some queries this video where
we can select select items based on
what's in the database so searching for
specific titles selecting specific
Columns of this table and then
eventually we're going to come and
create this application that you see and
display the data on the front end you
might call it or on the form of the
application so let's go take a look at
where we were and then we're going to
get closer to the vision that you see
here on the screen so as a reminder we
built our application using this tool
here map which includes MySQL as its
database so I've got the two little
green dots here indicating that the
application is running and the database
is being served now I'm going to click
this button here that says Open start
page so here is the start page as you
can see the address is localhost map I'm
going to the tools menu and choosing my
admin and I'm going to take a look at
the database here so Music 2 is what we
created in the last video and so far we
have an albums item so you can see on
this screen now that I have several
items that I imported in the last video
so I have a bunch of albums from the
Beatles so I have the title The Artist
the year the image name and the
description both of those items at the
end were taken directly from Wikipedia
so in this video we're going to practice
doing some selections and then in the
next we're going to do some programming
actually in the form so let's go to the
part that says SQL and we're going to
learn how some SQL queries work so as
you can see there is automatically some
code written for us which is very
helpful let me zoom in a little bit so
we can see very well on the video there
we go so select star it says from albums
where one so let's make this even
simpler I'm going to take out the where
collection and just say this statement
select star from albums and let's click
go and see what that does so what this
is telling us is Select everything that
there is in the albums table and you can
see that the list here includes all of
the items now we're going to do a little
bit more sophisticated searches than
that so let's focus in on this last part
where it says where so where is going to
be a condition so we can say some name
like ID and then I'm going to put in an
equal sign and then specify a specific
number so let's try three so I I just
happen to remember that the first album
in my table is ID3 so if I click on go
we're going to see exactly one result
because album 3 here is Abby Road so
let's try a different search so I'm
going to say where ID equals something
else I'm going to put in 17 I believe 17
is one of my albums so let's click go
and sure enough it looks like Hard Day's
Night in my collection is number 17. so
that is one way to do a SQL statement
now let's do another where we can have a
condition to say something like I want
to look for where ID is anything greater
than 10 and let's choose a go and this
time you can see that I have two items I
have 16 and 17 which are bigger than 10.
you can experiment with others let's try
something like a less than sign so let's
say if I say ID is less than 10 and what
comes out now so we get ourselves uh
four of them so three four five six
seven are the results here so you can
see that the SQL statements are able to
select items based on a condition all
right so now we're going to do another
query and this time I'm going to search
in the title of the album so let's see
if we can find anything that has the
letter A in the album title so this will
hopefully find things like Abbey Road so
the way we do this is we put in the word
album title after the word uh where so
where album title now instead of an
equal sign I'm using a like operator so
like says we're going to match a partial
match and so I want to match something
that is like the letter A let's see if
this does anything now before I click
the Go Button I'm going to make sure
that this box down here called retain
query box has a check mark that will
allow me to come back and modify this
without retyping the entire s so let's
go ahead and choose go and I am
disappointed the results down below says
it returned an empty set so nothing like
a so what is missing here is the ability
to search for wild cards so I'm going to
put in a percent sign before the a and a
percent sign for the after which means
find a somewhere in the middle of the
word let's see if that does any better
so I click go so let's look at the
results down below and you can see that
there are three results it says here
Abbey Road Yellow Submarine and Hard
Day's Night were all matched and so this
here is a like statement that gives us a
result so the percent sign and the like
operator are both important now a couple
other things that we're going to notice
here is these back ticks so how do you
type those if you're working in your
application because we're going to be
copying and pasting these search queries
into our Visual Studio application these
are actually optional so I'm going to
delete the back ticks they're only
useful is if you need them for uh
holding a space in your uh in your query
so if I click go the query works just
like it did before if I had something
like album collection as my name for the
uh table I would have to put in those
back ticks as you see it here but for
right now we don't need them so I'm just
going to back out to where I was before
all right let's do another go just to
make sure that it's still working okay
so I have three albums now what if I
only care about retrieving a certain
pieces of these data so for instance if
I wanted to know the album title and I
cared about the year just those two for
some reason that's what my application
needed so instead of the star I would
erase that and change it to something
else so if I type in something like an a
you're going to see that there are
suggestions here so album title is what
I want to select I'm going to put a
comma and what was the other I wanted a
year so I'm going to put in the word
year and those two column names show up
from the results down here let's see if
that works and I choose go and the
results now indicate that I'm only
getting two columns in my response so if
I'm ignoring everything else in my
database I can do specific searches
using the column names let's say I want
to rename these search results for some
reason I can say album title as as the
word title and year as let's make it up
how about date of publish you can use
any name you want really let's choose go
and let's see what that does at the
bottom so now you can see that the the
titles of the results now are renamed so
title and date of publish are the exact
same column names it's just that I've
renamed them that is something that
people do frequently when they have to
for some reason match up a a property in
their application to a column name in a
database and so here is a couple of
examples that we've done so let me
summarize what all done the screen here
of all of the queries that you just
wrote so first of all we did just a
standard query where we selected
everything then we did a query where
there is a greater than or a less than
sign then we did a query with likes and
we indicated that we had to have wild
card characters before and after a
string if we want to get accurate
results for the likes then we wanted to
be able to select certain column names
and so the column names are specified
instead of the star so star gives you
all columns in a table and you can
specify just a few columns if you need
to and ignore the rests and then finally
we have some searches where we rename
the column results where we say rename
the title as title and the year as date
of publish so those are some of the
things that you can do with SQL now
there's a lot more things to do with the
SQL searches but I will leave those for
another exercise in the meantime we're
anxious to get this thing working in our
application so in the next video we're
going to create an app that will display
the search results that we've done here
and put them on a form in a Windows app
so let's get started with building that
app next
if you would like to look at the full
series of this thing you can either
subscribe to the channel that you're
looking at now on YouTube or you can see
the more extensive version on
studycoding.org which is another website
[Music]
hi in this second video of a series
we're going to continue to explore
building a SQL database application
here's the index of all of the things
we're going to learn in the first video
we worked through creating our first
database in this video we're going to
start to write some queries using the
SQL language in the future we're going
to talk about the front end connecting
our database to that front end doing
some searches inserting records creating
foreign Keys joining tables together
creating what's called uml diagrams
making compound queries or multiple
queries in one step we're going to
delete items from the database and then
finally at the very end of this course
we're talking about features that we
didn't get to but you could probably
explore so this whole series here is
available not only here where you're
watching but also on
studycoding.org which is my channel
where I create applications my name is
sluter and I welcome you to come to
class with me virtually even where you
can become a professional software
developer so this course that we're
covering right now is focusing on
databases but as you can see from the
selections on studycoding.org that you
can learn c-sharp programming for
websites or Java or node.js and
JavaScript and other languages so many
of my students have become professional
software developers and have great jobs
and I'd like the same thing to happen
for you so come along and join us in
class and plan your future so just as a
reminder where we're going with this
application this is the final product
and as you can see we have a list of
albums at the top of the page and then
we have a list of music or tracks at the
bottom and then a YouTube player so that
we can hear the music so in the past
video we created the database that goes
behind this top control which is a grid
and we're going to work on some queries
this video where we can select items
based on what's in the database so
searching for specific titles selecting
specific Columns of this table and then
eventually we're going to come and
create this application that you see and
display the data on the front end you
might call it or on the form of the
application so let's go take a look at
where we were and then we're going to
get closer to the vision that you see
here on the screen so as a reminder we
built our application using this tool
here map which includes MySQL as its
database so I've got the two little
green dots here indicating that the
application is running and the database
is being served now I'm going to click
this button here that says Open start
page so here is the start page as you
can see the address is localhost map I'm
going to the tools menu and choosing my
admin and I'm going to take a look at
the database here so Music 2 is what we
created in the last video and so far we
have an l item so you can see on the
screen now that I have several items
that I imported in the last video so I
have a bunch of albums from the Beatles
so I have the title The Artist the year
the image name and the description both
of those items at the end were taken
directly from Wikipedia
so in this video we're going to practice
doing some selections and then in the
next we're going to do some programming
actually in the form so let's go to the
part that says SQL and we're going to
learn how some SQL queries work so as
you can see there is automatically some
code written for us which is very
helpful let me zoom in a little bit so
we can see very well on the video there
we go so select star it says from albums
where one so let's make this even
simpler I'm going to take out the where
collection and just say this statement
select star from albums and let's click
go and see what that does so what this
is telling us is Select everything that
there is in the albums table and you can
see that the list here includes all of
the items now we're going to do a little
bit more sophisticated searches than
that so let's focus in on this last part
where it says where so where is going to
be a condition so we can say some name
like ID and then I'm going to put in an
equal sign and then specify a specific
number so let's try three so I I just
happen to remember that the first album
in my table is ID3 so if I click on go
we're going to see exactly one result
because album 3 here is Abby Road so
let's try a different search so I'm
going to say where ID equals something
else I'm going to put in 17 I believe 17
is one of my albums so let's click go
and sure enough it looks like Hard Day's
Night in my collection is number 17. so
that is one way to do a SQL statement
now let's do another where we can have a
condition to say something like I want
to look for where ID is anything greater
than 10 and let's choose a go and this
time you can see that I have two items I
have 16 and 17 which are bigger than 10.
you can experiment with others let's try
something like a less than sign so let's
say if I say ID is less than 10 and what
comes out now so we get ourselves uh
four of them so three four five six
seven are the results here so you can
see that the SQL statements are able to
select items based on a condition all
right so now we're going to do another
query and this time I'm going to search
in the title of the album so let's see
if we can find anything that has the
letter A in the album title so this will
hopefully find things like Abbey Road so
the way we do this is we put in the word
album title after the word uh where so
where album title now instead of an
equal sign I'm using a like operator so
like says we're going to match a partial
match and so I want to match something
that is like the letter A let's see if
this does anything now before I click
the Go Button I'm going to make sure
that this box down here called retain
query box has a check mark that will
allow me to come back and modify this
without retyping the entire s so let's
go ahead and choose go and I am
disappointed the results down below says
it returned an empty set so nothing like
a so what is missing here is the ability
to search for wild cards so I'm going to
put in a percent sign before the a and a
percent sign for the after which means
find a somewhere in the middle of the
word let's see if that does any better
so I click go so let's look at the
results down below and you can see that
there are three results it says here
Abbey Road Yellow Submarine and Hard
Day's Night were all matched and so this
here is a like statement that gives us a
result so the percent sign and the like
operator are both important now a couple
other things that we're going to notice
here is these back ticks so how do you
type those if you're working in your
application because we're going to be
copying and pasting these search queries
into our Visual Studio application these
are actually optional so I'm going to
delete the back ticks they're only
useful is if you need them for uh
holding a space in your uh in your query
so if I click go the query works just
like it did before if I had something
like album collection as my name for the
uh table I would have to put in those
back ticks as you see it here but for
right now we don't need them so I'm just
going to back out to where I was before
all right let's do another go just to
make sure that it's still working okay
so I have three albums now what if I
only care about retrieving a certain
pieces of these data so for instance if
I wanted to know the album title and I
cared about the year just those two for
some reason that's what my application
needed so instead of the star I would
erase that and change it to something
else so if I type in something like an a
you're going to see that there are
suggestions here so album title is what
I want to select I'm going to put a
comma and what was the other I wanted a
year so I'm going to put in the word
year and those two column names show up
from the results down here let's see if
that works and I choose go and the
results now indicate that I'm only
getting two columns in my response so if
I'm ignoring everything else in my
database I can do specific searches
using the column names let's say I want
to rename these search results for some
reason I can say album title as as the
word title and year as let's make it up
how about date of publish you can use
any name you want really let's choose go
and let's see what that does at the
bottom so now you can see that the the
titles of the results now are renamed so
title and date of publish are the exact
same column names it's just that I've
renamed them that is something that
people do frequently when they have to
for some reason match up a a property in
their application to a column name in a
database and so here is a couple of
examples that we've done so let me
summarize what other than the screen
here of all of the queries that you just
wrote so first of all we did just a
standard query where we selected
everything then we did a query where
there is a greater than or a less than
sign then we did a query with likes and
we indicated that we had to have wild
card characters before and after a
string if we want to get accurate
results for the likes then we wanted to
be able to select certain column names
and so the column names are specified
instead of the star so star gives you
all columns in a table and you can
specify just a few columns if you need
to and ignore the rests and then finally
we have some searches where we rename
the column results where we say rename
the title as title and the year as date
of publish so those are some of the
things that you can do with SQL now
there's a lot more things to do with the
SQL searches but I will leave those for
another exercise in the meantime we're
anxious to get this thing working in our
application so in the next video we're
going to create an app that will display
the search results that we've done here
and put them on a form in a Windows app
so let's get started with building that
app next
if you would like to look at the full
series of this thing you can either
subscribe to the channel that you're
looking at now on YouTube or you can see
the more extensive version on
studycoding.org which is another website
[Music]
hi and welcome to another video in this
project here with our SQL database
application in this index we're showing
all of the things that we're doing in
this course in the first two videos we
created a database and then we ran some
queries in this video we're going to
create the front end so we're going to
actually start creating an application
in Visual Studio that will be able to
display the results of any queries that
we do against our database in the future
we're going to have these topics after
we finish all of that there'll still be
more left on said so there'll be future
plans that you can Implement so my name
is Chad sluter and I teach software
development at Grand Canyon University
in Phoenix Arizona and so I'm glad that
you're here you're going to become a
professional software developer if
you're able to do these kinds of tasks
so my website is studycoding.org where
you'll find all of the courses that I've
taught over the past years so not only
with web development and databases but
with mobile applications and security
and other issues so check it out and if
you like anything there you can join for
a small fee and get the source code so
let's take a peek at the application as
it is in its finished state so you can
see that we have tables that are being
searched and then we're playing some
music so these are all albums that are
from the Beatles and then tracks on each
of those albums and then a player here
so we can see a YouTube video now what
we're going to do in this video is we're
going to focus in on this section up
here where we're able to display the
albums and do searches against them so
in the previous video we set up the
database now we're going to create the
application that does the front end all
right so now let's talk about the
different ways that people use
applications when they are talking to
databases the app that we're going to
build here is a very simple app and
that's why I chose this desktop app to
do it it doesn't take much effort to
learn how to do this front end however
if you want to become a Prof
professional software developer you
should probably learn how to create web
applications now I have tutorials for
how to do that in different languages so
C sharp is a very popular choice for
creating web apps and so the keyword
that you're looking for is asp.net and
that is the framework that Microsoft
uses to connect websites to databases
and create a fully functional web page
that is an application
an even more popular way to create
websites with a common language is Java
so spring boot is the key word that you
should be looking for when you're
looking for Frameworks on how to build
websites with Java and of course I have
a tutorial for how to build a Java web
application another very popular choice
for building websites is using the
language PHP and as a matter of fact the
application that you see in this
tutorial is map which includes PHP as
its default language interpreter and so
PHP is also available on studycoding.org
if you want to learn how to build
websites with that language also you can
work with pure JavaScript if you work
with the Express framework on node.js
you can build a website in the same
manner that other websites are built in
other Frameworks so there's lots of
different choices that you can pick from
to build a website why are we then not
building a website you might ask because
this class is focused in on SQL and the
databases that go with it so it's very
simple to build the application that
we're about to right now but if you want
to be more advanced if you want to be
more employable then you should probably
take some of the other courses that I
offer or others do on how to build
websites and connect them to databases
like MySQL anyway we're trying to build
this app so what we have on the screen
is our final product and we're going to
implement just the first part here and
let's get started so as you can see I
have the database still running in the
background here so I actually don't need
that right now so I'm going to just push
that off onto my other desktop okay so
let's get started with Visual Studio you
can see that I have two versions
installed on my computer I have 2022 and
2019 so honestly 2019 Works a little bit
faster on my old computer but since
we're in 2022 we might as well get with
the times and show you this bigger
heavier version that is going to have
all the features we need so here it is
this is the startup screen to say what
kind of projects would you like to open
or build so I'm going to select the item
that says create a new project and I'm
going to make sure that I select the
right places so the templates up here
you can search for or you can filter
them using these choices so I want to do
c-sharp Windows app and a desktop then
I'm going to go go down and pick one of
these two options now Microsoft is
really good at confusing people about
which one is which what is the
difference between a Windows forms app
and a Windows forms app with NET
Framework well in the in the description
this one says it uses.net framework
these two things are different even
though they have very confusing and
similar language so I believe the choice
that I made for this one to get the most
current is the first item that says
Windows Form app and Net Framework below
is not the choice that is for an older
version so let's try next and see what
happens so now I need to create this
with some kind of a name so I'm going to
say this is a database SQL music app and
I'm going to leave the other choices the
same you can see the location where I'm
putting this is on my desktop and let's
choose next now I know that I've chosen
the correct application type because of
the next screen so the framework that
pops up next is version version 6.0
of.net so it says long term support So
at the time of this video here in 2022
this is the most current version that I
can program if you pick something that's
older than this frankly it will work
just just as well probably but 6.0 is
what we've got right now and if you're
from the future uh this will probably
still continue to work very similar so
I'm not doing anything that is cutting
edge with the.net framework so I'm
picking the current one just because
that's a good practice okay let's create
it and then give it a minute to build
everything
all right everything came out so we have
form one here and I'm just going to
click the green button at the top that
says make this application run I just
want to test it out to make sure
everything's good and I should see an
app on the screen so sure enough Here
Comes form one and I could minimize
Visual Studio in the background so that
way I have my beautiful blank app to
look at on the beautiful background now
I'm going to put two things on this
screen to get started with and then
we're going to start connecting our
application to the database
so the two things that I'm going to put
on here are button and then some kind of
a data grid that I can use to display a
bunch of pieces of data so the button
we're going to drag in from our common
controls area and I'm going to change
the text to the button so that it says
load albums so at least the user knows
what that button is supposed to do
let's make it a little bit wider so it
all fits then the second item that I'm
looking for is in the data controls area
so I search for something called the
data grid View and the data grid view is
really why we're building this app in
Windows forms because it requires no
configuration almost none anyway so
it'll be able to display data from the
database and of course I need to make
this wider I've got kind of a poor user
interface design when we're finished
here we're going to have a whole bunch
of stuff on one screen which is very
easy to program but really if I were
teaching this as a user interface class
and a user experience I would have
multiple forms but remember the focus on
this course is on SQL and how to make
the database work so that's why our app
is going to look kind of busy on the on
the main form so I got this thing here
with a with a form and it has a button
and a grid control next I'm going to
have an album class so this is a data
class in object-oriented programming
that will connect our properties in the
in the in the class with the the column
names in our database table
now I'm recalling all of the things that
I put into the database as I create this
album class each property here is going
to represent a string or an integer or
something like that some data type that
is in an album so the first thing that
each album has is an ID number so I type
in prop and then press tab tab to get
the property of an integer the first
thing is called ID the second property
is the album's name so you could call it
album title you can call it album name
I'm going to purposely not name this the
same thing as my database because I want
to make sure that we we handle certain
exceptions or certain cases when there's
discrepancies between a class name and a
table name generally people like to keep
them the same but I'm purposely making
them different here just to highlight
some things then we go on we're going to
have the artist name so in my case it's
always the Beatles and then the next one
is a year so an integer value for the
year comes up
we're going to make an image URL so this
is the title image of the album so this
is not the URL for the song The you the
YouTube song yet this is just an image
of what we got out of Wikipedia and also
from Wikipedia we grab the first
paragraph which is the description so
that also matches as a string type so
I've got a bunch of properties here that
are corresponding to the table that we
made in the previous video all of these
things about an album
now I know that later I'm going to add
some songs to the album but I want to
keep this simple for this video so I'm
just going to leave comments now to say
that coming soon is a list of type track
and this list of tracks will be
associated with the album but right now
we're just going to put in the comments
because we're doing one thing at a time
okay so we got ourselves a bunch of
properties now I'm going to make some
data and put it into our form and we'll
connect to the database in a while but
for right now I just want to create some
dummy data that will make sure that this
grid has something to look at
now I want to handle all of the database
operations in another class and it will
be the kind of the interface between the
app and the the table so I'm going to
call this thing albums Dao so Dao is a
shortcut for data access object its job
is to be able to do all the queries and
then it'll provide a layer between these
the front end and the back end
so just to make sure that we keep these
things kind of simple in each video I'm
going to first of all construct this
thing without connecting to the database
itself I'm going to create some dummy
data and then we'll display it in the
grid so we're not going to keep this
code here for very long it's just a test
I'm going to type the word list and an
Open Bracket and one of the nice
features that you get of Visual Studio
2022 is the type ahead help and it
predicted correctly that I wanted to
make a list called albums it's a list of
type album what it did not predict was
that I wanted to initialize the list so
it has some list value in it it's not an
empty list it's not a null list it's got
It's got values so it's a it's a list of
zero values but it still is defined all
right so this is just a placeholder
right now we're just going to create an
empty list now let's go into form one
and let's create some events that will
fill this list with some fake data so
I'm going to switch over to form one
design and I'm going to double click on
the load albums and so now we have an
event for this button click so button
click one
now this is going to be temporary code
we'll delete in a few minutes but we're
just going to test it out so I'm going
to add the album's Dao class and
initialize it with a new instance of
this class so when we click the button
it'll create a brand new list from
scratch every time we click it now as
soon as I have the list created I'm
going to start filling it with some data
so let's create a new album I'll name
this thing as an album of A1 and after
we create the new album let's fill it
with some properties so the first item
that we're up to is ID so id1 sounds
good to me let's take the album name to
be my first album and I might as well be
the artist so put my own name in there
the year is 2022 let's put in an image
URL of nothing yet I guess I don't know
what URL I want for the picture
for the description let's put in nothing
special so now we have A1
and we might as well make this have two
albums since it is a list so I'll copy
and paste to album one and I'll name the
second one as A2 and change the first
name so it is my second album
now what I'd like to do is add the first
song to my album's Dao so I'm going to
try that but I'm going to come up with a
problem so it says albums Dao dot albums
now there's a list of albums in there
but I can't see it for some reason but
it allows me to continue ahead typing
and add A1 so why can't I actually add
something to at albums A1 let's see it
says in my problem help it says it's
inaccessible due to its protection level
so means I probably made it private and
I could turn it public so that I could
actually do the thing that I'm trying to
do now so let's go back to the albums
Dio and sure enough let's go here and
change this to public and we'll save it
and now what happens when I come back to
my form one so the error goes away looks
like that was the problem and we've
solved it
now very helpful I go to the next line
and I type in an A and I get some type
of head help and it guesses that I want
to add the second album to the list okay
great so all of that work was to Simply
add two albums to our list of data now I
want to associate this list with the
control that's on the screen now one of
the tricky Parts about building an
application with c-sharp and windows
forms is called a binding source so a
binding source is the ability to connect
a list of items such as albums to the
control so the grid control and so I'm
just going to Define this here and
you're going to kind of follow along to
see how the format works so binding
source is the class name that is allowed
to connect these two and I'm going to
let the type ahead help me to call it a
new binding Source now I'm going to
rename The Binding Source because I'm
going to specifically have one for the
albums and another one later for the
tracks so I'm going to name this one as
the album binding source so so to make
that work or make that binding Source
work we're going down to the click
button action and so after I've added a
couple of albums I'm going to create a
connection between the lists and the
grid view so this is where the binding
Source comes in
so I'm going to Define this thing as the
album binding Source Dot and get a
property called data source and I'm
going to set that equal to B the list
that I made so it is the albums Dao and
it's not as smart as I thought I have to
add a DOT and tell it that the list is
called albums so putting these two
together should allow the grid source to
show these two new albums now there's
one more final step that we have to do
we have to tell the grid view that this
binding source is associated with it so
I type in data grid view one dot and it
has a property called data source and so
programmatically we're setting it up to
be equal to this list okay so now all of
this connection should be done correctly
at least I think it is let's try it I'm
going to run the app so I click the
little green triangle at the top and
let's see what happens so I've got the
app let's see I'll minimize the rest of
this so it's kind of out of the way and
uh what does Cortana up to get out of
the way okay so here we go now I'm going
to choose load albums and look at there
so The Binding source of these two
albums now displays all of the squares
in like a spreadsheet grid so that's the
magic of this control it automatically
creates a number of columns it needs and
if these get to be too long it allow it
puts in scroll bars and so this is
easier to do than if you're trying to
create some kind of a web page most of
this binding source and data source does
the work for you all right so that is
not exactly what we want we have a
couple of albums they're nice albums but
they're not the real ones what I want to
do is get all those Beatles albums that
are in the database and so we have still
not connected our database to the
control although you can see we are
almost there so in the next video we're
going to do that we're going to set up a
connection between the SQL server and
the app that you see here and then we'll
get the data live from the database so
let's take a look at the index of where
we've been so you can see that we're on
part three which is building a front end
so the front end is got some pieces to
it it's not complete but at least we can
see where we're going what's next next
is to connect that app that we just
started and connect it to the database
so we're not using fake data anymore
we're getting the actual albums from the
Beatles And so that will be the next
task that we do so we're on part four
coming up
[Music]
right
hi welcome back to another SQL
application tutorial so we're in an
application Series which is about
building applications using MySQL we did
part three already and now we're moving
on to part four so in the previous
videos we've created some tables and now
we're about ready to connect those
databases to the front end of our
application so the other parts that are
coming up are going to help us do
searches and to make more complex
queries and eventually we're going to
get to the point where we have a fully
functioning app so if this is
interesting to you then let's keep right
on going my name is Chad sluter and I
teach software development and computer
science at Grand Canyon University so so
many of my students using these
tutorials have become professional
software developers so congratulations
on choosing a good path for a good job I
hope you have a great future now here is
the application where we left it from
the last video where we had a simple set
of fake data we had two albums in our
data access object and they really don't
relate to the database yet however they
look like the albums that we put into
the database so we're getting closer so
by the time you're done here you're
going to see the application show all of
the Beatles Albums on the screen instead
of these two fakie alright so let's go
modify this data access object and make
it work like it's supposed to so we're
going to delete all the junk that was
already in our Dao and we're going to
add some new things so in this first
step we have to make a connection to our
database so every database has a
username and password authentication or
some kind of a way to make sure that the
right people are looking at the database
and so ours is going to be very simple
to start with the first property that we
put in is called the data source so the
data source is where does the server
live now if we were on the internet we
would put in some kind of an IP address
or we would put in Amazon aws.com or
some detailed long name for a server
since localhost is here that means we're
talking to the map server so remember we
have this map server running here and
this thing is running on localhost so
we're we're essentially doubling up our
computer to do two things one is the
application and the other is the
database server in real life sometimes
these are divided into separate machines
but anyway we're using localhost for now
next we need to specify something called
a port so let's bring in the map server
again and check out to see where this
might be so let's go to map and choose
preferences and let's see what else we
can do it says a bunch of stuff about
PHP what I'm interested in is ports so
in this tab here we can see that there
are ports so 80 is currently this the
setting for my web server and then 3306
is the port for our SQL database
supports are there's just numbers that
computers agree to communicate on like
it's like a channel it's like on your TV
when you have Channel
15.1 and 15.2 it's like they're the the
dot part is the sub Channel or it's the
port number for a major channel so our
port number here is 3306.
now we need to specify how to log into
this server so username and password is
what we need to provide now I know that
the username and password for my
particular map installation is root and
the password is root and if you're using
USB web server or a wamp you might have
something slightly different so check
the help files or the installation guide
if this doesn't work for you so root and
root works for map
the last item on the list is telling it
which database it needs to connect to
and as you might recall the name is
music 2. so just bringing up music too
is right here just refreshing our memory
of what we have for data now the way a
data access object works is you create a
bunch of methods that are going to
perform actions for the main program so
the first action that I'm going to
create is one that will get all of the
albums from the database so the return
type of this function is called a list
of type album
and then appropriate name for this would
be get or fetch or search for all so I'm
going to name it as get all albums
because I think that's the most clear
now to make this work I'm going to start
by creating an empty list of albums and
then I'm going to return that list at
the end of the function so I'm going to
rename the list as return these
so the next step is we're going to
create a connection so I'm going to type
in something that will not work at the
first it's called My SQL connection and
it's a new class so I will create a new
class and one parameter in it is the
connection string now why doesn't it
work well by default Microsoft expects
you to be talking to a SQL Server that's
their version of SQL but we built this
thing with mySQL so we have to go get a
extra piece of software called the
dependency to make this work so let's
see if the computer is able to help us
out in our problem so I'm going to hover
here and it says I have no idea what
you're talking about my SQL connection
doesn't exist in my list of known
classes let's see if there are potential
fixes so the first few fixes are you can
generate this and create your own
however you can see that there is a
mysql.data or data different
dependencies so let's go ahead and
choose this and it says I'm going to
install this so how is it going to do
that let's go ahead and choose find the
latest version and install it now I'm
going to just sit and watch and
magically something will happen and the
problem disappeared where did the
problem get resolved let's take a look
at how that is resolved so you can see
that the error is gone what I'm going to
do is right click on the project go down
to nuget packages so manage nuget
packages is the dependency manager in
SQL and you can see that it says here
I'm looking at installed packages and
mysql.data is already been installed and
it comes from the Oracle Corporation now
Oracle actually owns MySQL they paid
quite a bit of money for it and I guess
owning free software is maybe a status
symbol do they actually make any money
on MySQL they must somehow I'm not quite
sure how they do it but anyway they are
the owners of MySQL and they manage this
extra dependency that allows us to
connect using their classes here so
apparently it's working I'm going to
close the nuget package manager now the
next step that we're going to do is
we're going to create an open connection
so I'm going to type in my connection
and type dot open and that will log in
to the server
now there's going to be a whole bunch of
more stuff coming up here we're going to
do a SQL statement and then we're going
to execute it but I want to first check
to make sure that everything is
connecting properly so I'm going to skip
some lines and then just type return and
then the the list called return these so
right now it's still an empty list but
it will not be an empty list for very
long now I want to make sure that I can
test this out so I'm going back to form
one in the code here and I'm going to
start removing all of the junk that we
put in earlier so I'm going to delete
the majority of the junk that we put in
earlier and just leave this binding
source as the item so I'm going to
create a new instance of the album's
data access object so we'll do albums
Dao equals a new albums Dao now I want
to associate the data source of this
grid with the event called get all
albums so I'm going to just erase the
one piece of code here at the end on the
right and change it to get all albums
now remember get all albums is still
returning to empty lists but it will try
to connect to the server let's let's
just run this and see if there are any
errors okay the application's up and
running let's go ahead and choose get
all albums and it returned an empty list
you can see it must have must have
connected correctly let's let's try to
break that and see if there's a problem
that we can resolve later so I'm going
to go in and change something so
localhost I could change any one of
these details so localhost X or I could
put in the wrong port number or I could
put in the wrong username any one of
those will cause this to break so I'm
going to put an X in for the server name
and then try it again so now when I
choose logo albums what happens
there I finally get an error something's
coming up here and what is it
it says no such host is known so you may
have gotten a different error based on
whether you change the password or the
port number but this is telling me that
the open connection did not work and so
the program stopped so that's one way to
test to see if you got the right
connection string or not all right let's
fix that so I wanted to actually work
now we're going to finish off with this
get all albums
so the next item down is where we're
going to write the SQL statement so I'm
going to create a new a new instance of
an object called a MySQL command
so I'll name it as command
the values that we're going to create
when we do the instantiation is two
parts first is the string which is the
actual SQL statement so we're going to
say select star from the albums table
and then we have to provide a comma and
then the connection that we defined
earlier next we're going to use a using
statement so this using statement it's
kind of like a while loop it says use
this object and then when it's done with
a loop then destroy the object so what I
want to do is create something called a
MySQL data reader and this reader will
be the result of executing the command
that we defined up on line 25. so this
reader then can be used in a loop to be
able to fetch each line now we're going
to go through each column in the data
table and we're going to associate it
with a new property in a class so we're
going to make a new album I'll name it a
and for each of the properties we're
going to go through the column names so
ID is going to be equal to the reader
dot get and we want to get the right
type of value so this is going to be an
integer so integer 32 is the size of the
data you could use other integer types
like 16 but 32 seems to work so we're
going to say at position 0 expect to see
an integer the next item is the album
name or the title so that is coming from
reader.getstring at the second column
which is item number one and then so on
we go down to the artist name and the
year and the image URL and then finally
the description notice that the index
number goes to 0 1 2 3 4 and 5. so there
are five numbers for six Columns of data
and we have to match up the data type
accordingly otherwise the program won't
work after we have the new album called
a we want to add it to our list so
return these dot add is the command that
will attach this as another item in our
search results now to clean up after
ourselves we want to close the
connection so sick bow might be smart
enough to close the connection for us
but it's always supposed to be here so
after you're done querying do
connection.close so this time we should
be able to run the app and instead of
getting just empty data we might see
something let's go ahead and try it out
okay the app is up and running let's see
what happens when I choose get load
albums okay and there they are so I got
lucky and everything worked out fine now
I'm going to create an error just to see
if we can do some troubleshooting so
let's close this and let's say I changed
one of these things instead of a five I
put a six what would that do what kind
of an error do you suppose that would
make it probably won't work but let's
see why let's go ahead and choose run
this and now it says here you have
specified an invalid column ordinal so
in other words I only had up to five and
you chose six so that one here is I
suppose that's in English
sometimes computer errors are hard to
understand let's say instead of
get int I accidentally put in get a
string so let's see what's get string
will do for us so what kind of an error
will that do so get string it not it's
not going to let me it says an ID is not
a string here's a really common thing so
let's say I make a mistake in my SQL
statement so instead of albums I put in
the word album and let's see if that
makes a difference let's run that
so now I got the application running and
I choose go and we got an issue it says
here an exception it says table music
two dot album doesn't exist so if you do
a typo in this statement right here
things aren't going to go well either so
albums is the name
another good practice in writing SQL
statements is not to rely on the star
for selecting all items from the table
this will make your code more rigid you
might say or more more specific but it
will also avoid error so if I change the
star to ID album artists and year and
all the rest of them it should still
work the same if I've typed those
correctly so I'm going to try it again
run the app and when I choose get albums
I've got a problem
it says here the problem is that there
is no such thing as image URL um what is
the image URL supposed to be so let's
bring that up here it is uh image name
okay so that's what it is let's fix that
okay so image name should work let's try
to run it again and see what happens
this time
okay here we go load albums and this
time they all seem to work like they're
supposed to so we've got ourselves a
working select statement we've got the
first section done of our application
now it would be kind of nice to be able
to search like right now I'm getting all
of the albums how do I do a search so
that I can only get some albums of the
ones that I'm interested in well that's
exactly what we'll do in the next video
we'll do a select statement using the
where Clause so that way we can do
searches on our collection
[Music]
foreign
hi and welcome back to another edition
of our SQL application tutorial in this
application we're demonstrating how to
use MySQL in various different stages of
app development so we're up to part five
which is how to create searches so if
you haven't caught the first four parts
how to set up an application how to set
up a database and how to do some queries
then go back in the playlist and check
those out right now we're trying to
create a searchable text box where we
can put in a partial word and then get
some search results from a list of
albums so there's a whole bunch more
stuff coming up so look at all of these
subjects that will make a complete app
and then of course when we get to the
end I'll give you some challenges so
that you can continue on with your
learning
my name is Chad sluter and I teach
software development at Grand Canyon
University in Phoenix Arizona a lot of
my students have become professional
software developers which I assume is
what you're trying to do here as well so
stick with me and you can also look at
my website at studycoding.org where you
can become a software developer with
c-sharp or Java make yourself mobile
applications or other things that are
important to the career of a software
developer so I'm glad you're here let's
get started now with doing searches so
that our application is more powerful
than it was before so I'm bringing up on
the screen here everything that we've
created and also a preview of where
we're going before the end of this video
so first of all you notice we have map
which is our database server and then we
have the visual studio application that
we have in front of us what's new in
this video is this box up here that says
search so if I were to put a letter in
like the letter a and choose search
you're going to see that only albums in
my database that have the letter A are
given as a result so you you can see
Abby Road Yellow Submarine and Hard
Day's Night let's try something else
like my and see if there's anything that
has the word my in it doesn't look like
it let's try another one so let's try h
e and you can probably guess that help
is one of the songs that the Beatles
wrote if I leave the search box empty
and choose search I should get all the
results and the button here that says
load albums still continues to work and
shows all of the albums in my database
so that's what we're going to build
right now Okay so we've just gone back
in time for one video and I am now left
with the state of the application as it
was before where we had a load albums
button but no search box so let's start
from this point and then move forward so
let's start with the user interface and
then we'll do the back end programming
in a minute so the user interface
changes are pretty simple we're going to
put a button on here and put the word
search on it and so that way we can at
least have an event so let's put the
text of search on the top and then we'll
also put a text box on the screen so a
text box is where we can enter in some
values and then use the contents of that
box to do the searching all right so
that's all the interface changes we're
going to make now let's start
programming so I'm going to go to the
search button and double click it and we
have a new button click Handler button
two click now for the first version of
this button I'm just going to steal all
of the code from button one which was to
search for everything in the database so
let's just copy and paste this is here
and then we'll make some modifications
so that way it will search for only
specific songs so the one important
change that we're going to make here is
changing the method that we're going to
rely on from our data access object our
Dao so instead of searching for
everything I'm going to rename this
method and provide it one parameter
we're going to name it as search titles
and then provide the contents of that
text box so the contents of the text box
are text box1 Dot text so those are the
only changes we need to make here in
form one to make it work but we need to
now add this event here because you can
see that search titles has an underline
red on it which means it doesn't exist
yet and we need to go fix that now so
let's go open up albums Dao and let's go
check to see what we have here so I'm
going to start selecting we've got this
get all albums method and so I'm holding
the shift key in the arrow to select all
the way down to the very last so this is
going to be be duplicated and then
modified slightly so I'm pressing Ctrl C
all right so now I've got the items
copied I'm going to create some space
here and then Ctrl V for a paste let's
see if I got one extra bracket it looks
like so let's take out him so that
little red thing goes away okay so now
I've got a duplicate of the method
called get all albums what I want to do
is change that to search titles inside
of the method I'm going to put a
parameter called string and we'll name
it search term so we're expecting to get
some information from the form so that
way we can query the database based on a
keyword search now let's save this and
go back to form 1cs and see if the error
goes away so sure enough now search
titles with a text box one text
parameter is now valid so the two
different methods two different methods
sync up well
so let's go back to the Dao and continue
working what I'm going to do first seems
like the logical thing to do but we will
CL will have errors let's type it out
anyway just see what the first
intentions would be if I were
programming this without some
documentation to look at so what I what
I want to do then is in the SQL search
string I want to add the where statement
and I want to say I want to search for
all albums where the album title is like
the search term and so will that work if
you remember from previous videos that
were missing the percent sign which is a
wild card character and so that's the
first problem that will cause this to
error out but there's another but anyway
I'm going to try and test it anyway so
let's put in a search term with a
percent and then a percent to follow it
and let's see if that works um I I'm
predicting it won't so let's just test
it and prove my point so I'm searching
for the letter a and then type search
and sure enough it doesn't work look at
the error it says you have something
wrong with your syntax right near the
word search term at line one and so now
we're baffled we tried to do this with
other searches in the past but for some
reason our application doesn't behave
like it did in the PHP my admin screen
so what are we going to do the first
thing I'm going to do is stitch together
a couple of things into a single string
so I'm going to name my string as search
wild phrase which is simply the search
term with an addition of a percent sign
at the beginning and another at the end
and so that's step one to make this
whole string work a little bit better so
now in my Brilliance I think well I can
just take that string now and attach it
to the SQL statement that I had before
will this work let's try it and see if
it doesn't
so I run the application and I type in a
letter and choose search and sure enough
we have the same error so I'm not
getting any closer well I am but I'm
trying to show you the common errors
that I went through as a first time
programmer and what you're probably
trying to do as well so we're going to
abandon this idea and move toward the
solution a further step toward the
solution is to get rid of this trying to
concatenate strings together and use a
placeholder so I'm going to put an at
symbol and search to make this happen
so let's figure out where I came up with
that so actually I looked in the
documentation believe it or not and
Microsoft tells us what to do what we're
trying to prevent is called SQL
injection attacks and so this great
article is very simple to understand if
you can go through the examples so let's
take a look at what they had for an
example code that they recommend not to
do it's exactly what I was trying to do
or you take a item and you try to
concatenate with plus signs and when
you're done you have a SQL statement so
it's it's vulnerable to hackers doing
things that you can do is called SQL
injection attacks and I'm not going to
go into that right now but if you look
in the description I can show you a
course that deals exclusively with SQL
injection and cross-site scripting all
kinds of security issues with
programming but for right now we're just
trying to get this thing to run let's go
down and we're going to go past example
two because it's doing the same thing
where we're concatenating strings and so
we're trying trying to find a solution
and sure enough it comes up with one so
the solution is this it's called
parameter queries and the way it looks
like is that we have to come up with
something that has an at symbol and then
we use uh let's see where is it we have
something where we do parameters right
here so we're going to have a command
that looks like that parameters add with
value so we're not going to do the exact
code here but something very close to it
so take time to read this article and
you'll be a lot smarter when it comes to
using a SQL app and avoiding SQL
injection attacks so to make this work
we're going to split up our Command item
here our Command object and put some
extra parameters into it so I'm cutting
out the SQL string and in the line 64
where it says make a new command I'm
just going to leave it with no
parameters just two parentheses then on
the following line I'm going to say I'm
going to add a parameter text or a
command text to this and it is the SQL
statement and I'm going to make sure
that I have the at search parameter in
there so it's a placeholder for
something else then following that
placeholder we're going to put a new
line in that says command.parameters dot
add with value and then I can tell the
computer that at search is really a
substitution for the search wild fruit
another line that we need to do is tell
the command what connection we're using
so I'll say command dot connection
equals and then we have a string up
above called connection which was
defined like way up at the beginning of
the of the of the class here so we have
a connection we have parameters and
command text let's see if this works so
I got the app running and let's try a
letter a and do a search and we've got
some results this time so it looks to me
like we've got exactly what we want so
let's try and search for the letter B
again and see what we got Let It Be
let's try the word uh l e and do we get
anything we got one song and if I take
all of the items out and do a search we
get the whole results so this to me
looks to like a search results that is
successful now in the next video we're
going to add a picture over here so
we're going to have the album photo on
the screen which is a pretty simple case
we've already got the image URL in our
database now can we make it show up on
the form well the answer is yes and it's
not very hard
foreign
[Music]
hi welcome back to another part for our
SQL application tutorial we're doing
here in this video we're going to
continue on building the interface for
our app so in the previous videos we've
done all of these items that you see on
the screen we're at the point now where
we can search for an album in our
database so what we're going to do in
the future is to continue on to build
all of these features until we have a
complete idea of how to use MySQL and so
continue on and we'll become a software
developer together so let's take a look
at the application as we're going to
finish today so you can see we have a
little icon on the screen that shows a
picture of the album cover and every
time I click one of the rows in my table
you can see that the album art is
displayed over here in the picture box
and so a couple of things we're going to
have to do to make this happen first of
all we're gonna have to put this picture
box on the screen of course the second
thing is that when we click the grid
we're going to have to find out what row
we're in and what column we're going to
get the information from and then load
that into the picture box so when all
that's done you'll have yourself what
you see on the screen here so let's get
started with the code okay so I've
reversed the application so now the
picture box is gone and we're ready to
start adding that feature now together
so I'm going to close this and start the
process so here's the process we're
going to take this form and put a
picture box on it so let's go find the
picture box first of all and let's see
it's called picture box right there it's
in winforms it's as simple as dragging
something onto the screen and changing
its size okay so now let's check to see
if we can add something to that box so
you can see that it's it's empty right
now
and uh there's multiple ways to put a
picture into a box what we're going to
do is use the URL from one of our videos
so to get one of the video URLs I'm
going to go to the PHP my admin page and
then I'm going to find the let's say the
first one here so let's do a control a
to control select it all Ctrl C to copy
it and then let's come back into the
visual studio now in here we're going to
be able to add this and I need some kind
of an event to do that for right now I'm
just going to choose load albums and at
the end of the album I'm going to load
this so let's see if I type in picture
one box one
and then there is a command for load I
believe it is yes
so it's as simple as telling it what URL
you want so I'm going to put in a
quotation marks paste in the string and
a semicolon so that should load an image
from the Internet it's as simple as that
so let's go ahead and run it and test it
out so when I click the load albums you
can hopefully see there is the picture
so that is Abbey Road if I click any of
these things it doesn't change so we've
still got that to go and it appears that
only the top left corner of the album is
showing so those are the things that we
still have to do but we have proven that
we can load a picture from the internet
first of all I want to change the
property of this picture so let's click
here and let's go down to the bottom
where it says appearances now what I'm
looking for is a way to scale this image
and I'm not quite sure which one was
uh here it is it's called size mode so
right now it's set at normal and let's
look at the choices so stretch might be
the first thing you think of but you can
get all kinds of weird warped pictures
the one we're looking for is zoom and
the others you can experiment with but
for right now we're just going to try
zoom and let's run it again to check to
check to see what kind of a picture look
that looks like so I click on load
albums and there I get the whole photo
so it's scaled proportionately and it
automatically adjusts to the frame very
nice so I'm not really interested in
seeing Abby Road every time I click the
grid I want to see the actual picture
that I'm supposed to get from the grid
so let's click the grid once now you
might be tempted to double click the
grid if you want an event to occur so
that's like clicking a button but in
this case what I want to do is to go to
the properties and choose the events and
look at my choices so the Mouse has a
click cell click contents and sell
double click so let's do click sell so
I'm in this Square here I'm just going
to double click here
and now I have a cell click event this
one works better than the other two I
can guarantee you that but just take my
word on it so now what I want to do is
check to see if this actually works so
the simplest way to do a test is to do a
message box and show it let's go ahead
and test it out okay so I'm going to
load some albums and then I'm going to
click something and sure enough it says
clicked so you can see I can click on
any cell in the grid and I get a clicked
message now how can I tell which cell I
clicked right now it's just kind of
generally saying you click to sell so
the key here is the word sender if you
look into the parameters that the click
event has sender is the item that is
sending this message so I'm going to
save the sender as a data grid view
object so I assume that the sender is
always the data grid View so I will just
say that is equal to the sender now you
can see that there is a problem so
sender is a generic object and data grid
view is a specific type of object so to
make this fix occur it says would you
like to do a cast so let's go ahead and
choose this and add the explicit cast
and tells it now that I guarantee you
that if this receives a click event it's
coming from a grid view so now I want to
capture some values about the grid so
for instance the row number so let's
create an integer variable and name it
row clicked we're going to get it from
the datagrid view dot current row dot
index so current row is the current row
that's selected and index is the row
number and then I'm going to do a
message box to show some feedback so we
can see if this is actually doing what
we want we want to get the row number
remember so let's go ahead and click the
go button and see what this message box
shows
so we show the albums first and now when
we click something you can see that it
says I clicked row number three now
count these down so Abby Road is zero
let it be as one help is two and then
revolver is three so it is not showing
me the album ID number it's showing me
the row number so this is row number
zero and let's see what the last one is
so it's not 17 it is row six so now that
I have the row number I can go get the
columns so if you if you count the
columns just like the rows we have ID is
zero album name is one artist Two at um
year is three and image URL would be
fourth so the fourth column of the row
that was clicked contains the string
that we want to put in the picture box
okay let's see if we can get all that in
code
okay so here's the process now we're
going to create another string and it's
going to be called image URL so we're
going to get this from the data grid
View and the type ahead help is really
pretty much right on here it's pretty
close I want to get the datagrid view
dot rows and then in square brackets
tell it which row number which is the
row clicked then I want to get the cells
so a little bit off on this one but
cells and I want to get cells the array
of cells at position four
and that's actually the fifth column and
then I'm going to get this value and
then change it into a string and then
I've got myself the value that I'm
trying to put into the picture box let's
put a message box out to test this one
and see if that's doing what we expect
let's run it again and check
okay away we go so we click on albums
and let's click something so it says
here you clicked row two and the image
URL is this thing is that indeed what
we're after so it looks like the Beatles
album cover uh oh help that's the word
help okay
let's try another one let's go to The
Abbey Road and do we get anything
so we got zero and then it looks to me
like Abby Road is in the file name so
we've we've got the right URL now all we
have to do now is put it into the
picture box
all right so I'm a little tired of
hearing these picture box things show up
so I'm going to comment them out so
they're out of the way
so the last statement that I'm looking
for is picture box one dot load and then
in parentheses I have to put the string
of that image and so that is a string
that we just created a minute ago it's
called image URL so that should load the
picture every time we click a cell let's
give it a shot and see what happens okay
the albums are loaded now and let's pick
somebody let's try let it be and it
looks like it help
and revolver
Rubber Sole they're all coming up
nice
so all of my pictures are being loaded
based on the image URL field that is
over here in column number five so the
next video that we're going to do is
going to be inserting new records so we
need to create a little data input form
and add new albums as the user chooses
to so let's do that in the next step
foreign
[Music]
hi in this video we're going to continue
on working with this tutorial on the SQL
database application so we've gone
through a few sections already and so we
are about ready to do inserts so we've
done searching we've done creating a
table what we're going to do now is add
records to a SQL database and so we'll
create a form and then we'll execute an
insert statement using SQL so here's the
rest of the tutorial so make sure that
you stick around to watch the entire
thing my name is Chad sluter and I teach
software development at Grand Canyon
University we're in the middle of a
process here to make you a software
developer so many of my students have
already graduated and gone on to get
great jobs and I'm trying to add you to
the list so make sure that you subscribe
or go to my website which is
studycoding.org where you can see all of
the things that we do in class so
welcome aboard so now I'm going to show
you where we're going to end at this
video so you can see the application
that we have in front of us here now has
a data entry form so I kind of shoved it
into the corner up here in the left and
you can see that I've already filled out
a whole bunch of items let's see where I
got that so if I switch back into
Wikipedia you're going to see that I've
been copying information such as the
description and the image URL and the
year so we have a new album to add to
our database so I've filled in all of
these fields here so Sergeant Pepper's
Lonely Hearts Club Band and the rest of
the items now I click the add button I
get a pop-up that says there's been one
record inserted now I want to either
click load albums to see everything and
you can see that number 19 is Sergeant
Pepper's or I can choose the search and
you can see that it also shows up here
so let's just type in an SG and search
and we got one item so it did insert
correctly and now I can search for it so
that's what we're going to have by the
time we're done with this video so let's
get started started with modifying our
application to look like this all right
so you can see that I've got the
application on the screen as we left it
in the previous tutorial now it's time
to put in this insert form so I'm going
to drag in a whole bunch of things and
arrange them inside of a container and
then we'll add some code okay so now
it's time to set up the rest of the
controls on arc form so let's put some
space up here in the upper left corner
so we can add some input Fields first of
all take the image for the album and
drag it over to the right so we create
some space
now I'm going to use a control container
so a container is one that is kind of a
grouping thing so we look in the
grouping section or the container
section and we find group box one so
we'll drag him in so the name of this
form or this sub form really is called
add album so we'll set the text to add
album so that way no the user knows
what's going on
now I'm going to put in a bunch of
labels so these labels are going to
indicate what we're entering so we're
going to skip the ID number first of all
just leave that out we're going to start
with the album name and so let's put in
an album name change the text value to
album name and then we'll do artists and
then we'll follow it with a year and the
image URL and the description
now I want to arrange these so we'll set
the left margin to be all equal and then
we'll also set it so that they're
vertically spaced so there's some
controls up here in the top in the ruler
or the in the in the control bar you
might call it where you can do all of
these arrangements so you don't have to
be very good at arranging things the
computer will help you with that
next we need to put in some text boxes
so let's drag in a text box for album
name now instead of leaving the name as
text box 2 as you can see here I'm going
to change the name of the control
because we're going to reference that in
our code so my convention from working
with other types of forms is to use a
prefix on every one of my controls so
txt indicates a text box and then an
underscore and then a description of
what that's for so txt underscore album
name is what I'll use for the next one
is txt underscore and we'll say artist
or album artists and so we'll put in
another text box for the year and we'll
set that to be year and then txt is the
prefix let's go with image URL and
description following the same pattern
so txt is the prefix that I always use
now you might have a different process
and many other tutorials will lead you
in another way but this seems to work
for me let's also arrange these so that
they're all nice and straight so we'll
choose a left margin so that they're all
lined up to the left and we'll also
spread them vertically
then we can finally maybe change their
width so they all match and then resize
the group box so it fits nicely and then
let's try to squeeze it into the upper
left corner of our form we might have to
move some of the other controls out of
the way to make this happen
but we will see that there might be
enough space there now this is kind of a
poor example of user interface design
and we're trying to squeeze everything
into one form simply because we're
trying to make this as easy to program
as possible this is not the way that you
would probably want to treat your users
if you were making a real app can you
imagine if you had a phone app with all
of these controls jammed on one screen
not a good idea but we're focusing in
the database right this is a SQL class
and we're making the simplest form
possible okay so we got the form set up
now we need a button and then an event
to go with it so that way we can talk to
the database so the last item is to
stick in a button called add so let's
create a little more space in our group
box and then we'll drag in a button and
let's just set the text of the button to
the word add
I'm going to double click on the button
so that way we have an event a click
event
and now we're going to program something
in here that will talk to the database
so the first thing I want to do is
capture all of those text inputs and
create a new album object so let's
define the new album object we'll call
it album and I'm going to create a new
one using an inline Constructor here so
we're going to create all of the
properties except for the ID so the
first item is the name so the name of
the album is going to get its value from
the text control so now you can see why
I use txt underscore as the prefix for
all of my text items they're real easy
to find on this help when you do type
assist so txt artists no it's called
album name and then we get the text
property of that text box the next item
is the artist name and let's choose the
txt artist name and ensure that you put
dot text then we're going to use the
year now this one's going to flag an
error because a year is an integer and
we're going to assign it a text value
don't worry we'll come back and fix this
so we're going to get the text from the
input box then we're going to have an
image URL and we'll get the same idea so
text image URL and then finally we're
having the description
so now we have all of the properties
except for the ID associated with
something from the form
so far so good now for that year what
are we going to do for that so the
command we're looking for is in the
integer 32 class so we'll type in int32
Dot and you can see that there is a
method called parse and it's its job is
to take a text field and convert it into
an integer so we'll just surround the
text property with parentheses and use
int32.parse this should all work as long
as the user fills out the fields
correctly so we're not doing any error
checking here remember this is a simple
app and we're talking about the database
issues and we're not trying to make a
user application so much
now that we have an album class we can
now try to add it to the database so
we're going to create a new instance of
the album's Dao which is the class that
we created in previous exercises so
we're going to create the new instance
and then I'm going to call on a method
that doesn't exist yet but we will
create that in a minute so the method is
add one album and in parentheses we use
the parameter album the one that we just
got from the form
now I am going to come back and fix this
underline error one other feature though
I want to do is have an integer result
come back from this method so that will
tell me if an insert was correct or not
so an integer value of result is what
we're going to get now we're going to
come back and finish this code a minute
but now we have to go and code in the
other class the albums Dao because right
now as you can see we have an underline
so let's go check the underline and it
says here the album's Dao does not
contain a definition for add one album
so we haven't programmed that yet let's
see if we can get some help here so show
potential fixes and the only fix that
says is would you like to create this so
sure enough I'll click it and somewhere
someplace somehow the error goes away we
need to go find it so I'm going to save
this and switch into albums Dao
and see what's there
so let's refresh our memory from what
was here so I scrolled to the top and we
have a class with get all albums then we
have another method down here called
search titles and then finally there's a
new one that was just inserted for us
called add one album now I'm going to
copy some of the code that we used in
previous examples and then we're going
to modify it so the simplest code I can
pick from is the very first method
called get all albums so I'll just copy
the contents of that method and paste it
into my insert command that I'm going to
do here at the bottom now I'm going to
erase most of the code but I do need to
keep around a thing like open the
connection and close the connection and
create a SQL command now the SQL command
is going to be drastically different but
it still is a command so I'll leave that
line now the command here is going to
have the select statement so let's
delete the select statement and we're
going to replace it with an insert
statement now I'm not very good at SQL
or maybe we're new at it let's say let's
go and have some help from our MySQL
admin page so I have here the admin page
for the MySQL server and up at the top
there is a SQL statement so I'm going to
get some help from here so as you recall
we were able to do select statements
with help here I'm going to choose the
insert button and it gives us an exact
line what we need to use as a model
isn't that handy so I'm just going to
copy the entire thing and then change it
once we get into our program so let's
copy here and then switch back into our
visual studio and paste it inside of
these quotation marks now let's see what
we need to change here so we have a
statement that says insert into albums
well that's the table that we want to
insert into and then you can see the
next section lists all of the column
titles that are in the table so which of
these column titles are we inserting
is the answer all of them
not quite we are treating the First
Column differently the ID number we
don't want to provide an ID number when
we insert because the table is set up to
automatically increment the counter
variable for ID and so in this statement
I'm going to erase the First Column so
ID does not include itself here
and so
album title is the first column now the
rest of these are valid now when we get
to the values here I'm going to also
replace those so let's select them all
and let's delete
now instead I'm going to use what our
placeholders so I'm going to use an at
symbol and then some name that refers to
this column
so referring to the rest of these we're
going to have the album title and then
an at for the artist name and at for the
year
then we're going to have an at for the
image URL and then an app for the
description so now it's time to adjust
the parameters so the command that we
want to use to associate a parameter
those at symbols with the actual value
is this command dot parameters Dot add
with value and then in parentheses we're
going to have two things the first is a
string which says which parameter name
are you trying to associate so the First
Column is the album title so we'll put
at album title
now the second item is the actual value
that we are using for the insert so we
have a variable called album
where did that come from so the album
dot album name is coming from the
parameter up on line 92. so when this
method is called it has to have an album
supplied to it so we've got the actual
data coming in there so that's this
first parameter then will associate one
property of the object with the first
parameter in the SQL statement
so the rest of these parameters are
going to be very similar so I'll copy
and paste so we're going to copy and
paste and then we'll switch the next one
to artists and the album dot artist name
is the actual value then we're going to
go to at year and we'll get that from
the property of the album year then the
third one or the fourth one is image URL
notice I'm using the capital letters so
that way they match exactly and then
we're going to have the image URL from
the album property and then finally the
description so all of these parameters
should work if the user fills out the
form correctly if they fill out the form
in a bad way if they put in strings for
the year for example then the Apple
crash so remember we're not checking for
errors in the input field we're making
this a simple user interface
so the next item is we have to execute
the query so let's type in command dot
execute and there the the one of the
first suggestions is called a non-query
execute non-query that means you're not
selecting anything we're doing an insert
so I guess that goes as a non-query now
it says here what we need is a statement
it says against the connection and then
it Returns the number of rows affected
well that's very handy because we want
to get those numbers of rows affected
and send it back so let's choose execute
non-query I'm going to press Tab and
then we have the execution now we need
to save this so let's put in a new value
value and call it result or let's call
it new rows and then we'll get it from
this execute non-query so that works out
well then finally when we want to return
something we're going to return the
number of new rows
and let's see if all of the errors go
away I believe they do good
now we're almost done but we need to go
back to form one and let's see what we
can add after the insert so the results
are here so I'm going to just put in a
message box so I'm going to say message
box show
and then we're going to tell it how many
different rows were inserted
okay so now we got everything set up it
looks like we're ready to run so we just
have to click the green button and try
it out
all right there's the beautiful looking
app let's minimize visual studio and
let's go back into our Sergeant Pepper's
let's see if we can use this so I'm
going to select the first paragraph and
let's put in the description below so my
user interface doesn't allow for much
space but as you can see I can put in a
very long text so the image URL I'm
going to work up the from the bottom so
let's go and write right click here
choose copy image address and let's
paste that into the image URL the rest
of these I think we can fill out so what
were the other ones we've got 1967 here
and then the artist that looks like the
Beatles
and then this is a lot of typing so I'm
going to copy the title and paste that
okay all that work now we're ready to
click the add button and what do we get
it says one new row is inserted and
let's choose a load albums and let's go
to the bottom and you can see that I've
put it in twice now and so if I click
one of these we get ourselves the URL
image that seems to be loading so I
inserted Sergeant Pepper's twice you
probably get one if you click the add
button you'll get two as well and you
get a whole bunch of them if you click
it multiple times the next thing that
we're getting to in this tutorial series
is creating a foreign key because now
that we've got albums we need to add
some tracks or individual songs and each
song is of course associated with an
album which is going to require us to
learn how to make two tables and a
foreign key so we're going to get
started with foreign Keys Next
[Music]
hi and welcome back to another section
of our SQL database application tutorial
I think this is part eight and we are
learning how to use SQL databases so
here's the index of everything that
we've learned so far you can see that
we've created tables and we've created a
simple app that can read and insert
records in this video we are going to
talk about foreign Keys you're going to
learn how to use a new tool that will
create links between tables so we will
have an albums table and then another
table in our database for each of the
songs we'll call it our tracks table and
then the relationship between them is
very important and so we'll learn the
how to use the tool called my SQL
workbench so a lot of Concepts here
about SQL databases that we're going to
explore right now here's the rest of the
sequence that we're going to learn so
we're about halfway through and by the
time you're done you will become a SQL
expert we might say my name is shad
sluter and I teach software development
at Grand Canyon University in Phoenix
Arizona I'm glad you've joined us so
many of the students that I've taught in
the past are now employed very
successfully as software developers so
I'm inviting you to come along and learn
some of the same things that we do in
class in this particular course SQL
databases you use this in almost all
types of software development so this is
an essential part of your education so
make sure you check out the website at
studycoding.org where you can see all of
the courses that I've been teaching in
the past few years so here's a preview
of what we're going to do before the end
of the video you can see on the screen
that I have a new tool up this is called
MySQL workbench and a workbench tool is
used to design databases so by the time
you're finished you're going to have not
only the albums table that you see here
but this link to another table called
the tracks table and so this this
contains all of the songs that each
album has and you can see there's a link
between the two called a foreign key and
so all these Concepts that we're going
to learn right now so if you haven't
installed this tool yet let's go and
find it so I'm Googling my SQL workbench
install so let's see what we got here
for one of the links and this is the one
you want here so MySQL workbench
download now and then you're going to
have the choice of which platform you
want to install so I'm using Windows you
might have something else but go ahead
and choose the download and go ahead and
run the setup and when you're finished
you will have the application that you
see on my computer so I've got the
application installed I'm just going to
click the little dolphin icon and run it
so you can see the first screen is
welcome to my SQL workbench now I'm
going to remove this item here because
you don't have that yet so let's see
delete the connection and click delete
so the first thing you do when you
launch this is try to connect your MySQL
workbench to a server now you can see in
the background that I have the map
server running and I have the green dots
indicating that the two servers are
active so the Apache server which
honestly we're not using but it's
automatically included in this package
MySQL server is also running so the tool
my SQL workbench will work with any type
of SQL MySQL server so whether you're
installing mamp or wamp or USB web
server or you just installed MySQL as a
standalone product they will all be able
to connect using MySQL workbench so you
might have a similar setup that I do but
hopefully something that is as close as
possible so that the tutorial makes
sense to you alright so let's see how we
can make this work so as you recall the
server here has a username and password
so root is the username and root is the
password for this particular instance of
my sequel so that's important to be able
to connect now I'm going to just
minimize this and now we're going to go
into my SQL workbench so now down here
in the section where the my SQL
connections are listed I'm going to
click the plus sign and this will add a
new connection now if you go if you
don't find that plus sign you can
probably find it over here under the
databases menu but I'm just going to go
with this plus sign so I'm going to set
up a connection so the name of the
server is localhost so that's a great
name for the connection
down below here is the IP address of my
server so I'm going to type in localhost
again you could leave it as
127.001 but localhost is synonymous then
the port number is 3306 so that's the
default port and if you want to check to
see if you're running on that Port you
go to your map server go to the map menu
pick preferences choose ports and you'll
see the port number listed here so this
is 3306 so I'm just going to cancel this
and minimize map so I'm just verifying
that 3306 is the correct number and it
likely is on your computer too
now I'm going to test the connection and
it says it was successful so if this is
not successful check your passwords
check to see if you've got the right
ports and everything
let's click OK and choose OK again
so now I've added a new connection down
here so I don't have to go through and
set up the connection again the next
time I run this application I can just
double click on this gray box which I'm
going to do now
so I've double clicked and hopefully
I've connected now you can see on the
left side here I have two tables I have
a music table and a music two table if
you don't see that you can switch
because you might have Administration on
this tab and then what I want to select
is schemas so the schemas are the
database names so let's take a look
inside of here so Music 2 is the
application that we've been working on
so I'm going to expand this choose
tables and you can see that there's an
albums table so if I were to expand that
further you can see the column names and
then you're going to see more details
about our our design so we have ID the
title The Artist the year the image and
the description so those are all the
items that we set up in the PHP admin
page and so you can see the same kinds
of materials here but my SQL workbench
will do more Administration tasks in an
easier way than the previous admin and
screen that we've been using up until
now
so what I want to do is add a second
table and make a foreign key so just to
see where we're going I'm going to
collapse music to
and I'm going to show you what music
looks like because I created this
application earlier
just to prepare for this tutorial
so to show you how this works I'm going
to go to database you won't be able to
do this yet so just watch I'm going to
choose reverse engineer
and I'm going to click next
and then I'm going to log in
and then click ok
now it says you've connected let's go
through this steps here so next
and it says which one of the schemas
would you like to connect to so Music 2
is the one we're currently using I'm
going to take that one off and I'll show
you the one that I created on earlier
tutorial so music is what I'm after
choose next it says so far so good with
green check marks next again it says
you're going to import two tables and
execute
and this time when I'm done something
happened in the background I click next
and then finally I click finish
and here we are so now you can see the
results of what we're trying to get to
so I have two tables I have an albums
table and a tracks table so that's where
we're going now let's back up and see if
we can get to this point so I'm going to
close these tabs at the top of the
screen and don't save whatever's there
and we're back
so I want to open up the music 2
database so let's try this again this
time you work with me all right so click
on database
choose reverse engineer
and then we're going to choose next
we're going to choose next
we're going to select music to
choose next
execute
and next and finally finish
okay so all of that work gets us to this
diagram
so what we're looking right now at is a
diagram called an eer diagram this is
the design of your database you can see
it has one table and it shows you all
the column names in it now we're going
to add a new table and then
re-synchronize our database to this
diagram
so there's a couple of steps involved
here and you have to do it exactly right
or it will give you an error so first of
all we're going to create a table so
over here in this column here you can
see that there is an icon that says
place a new table so I'm going to click
it and then click out here and I have
table one so table one doesn't have
anything in it of course it looks kind
of like a title only let's double click
it
so when I double click it I get another
bunch of things that I can configure the
first thing is I'm going to give it a
name so let's call this thing tracks and
press enter
now what are we going to have in the
tracks table let's go down to the
columns so the first thing you usually
do is you set up an ID and leave it as
an integer we're going to check Auto
increment as our option
the next item down so the next item down
I'm going to call it track title and so
I'll use an underscore character here
you don't have to use underscore you can
just shove them all together into a
single word if you like but I would
recommend that you do not use spaces in
any of your column names so this is
going to be a varchar type of column and
since the title of the album is probably
longer than 45 letters let's set it to
something bigger I'll choose 100
characters
so let's add some other items so after
the title let's put in another column
and we'll call it number so this is the
track number like if it's track number
one on the album so it's an integer so
usually there's about not eight to ten
tracks per album so we'll see some
number between 1 and 10. the next item
down that we're going to put is a string
so this is video underscore URL so this
will be a YouTube link so we can
actually play the video
so a number of characters that we're
going to need here is what maybe 200 or
so how long is a URL for a YouTube video
I'm not quite sure so 200 is a safe
number
let's add a lyrics column so the lyrics
will be all the words to the song and
for some reason we might want to print
that to the screen so a lyrics could be
really long so look at all of the
options for our different data types so
there's a lot of different options for
choosing a text field I'm going to
choose the one that has text and
parentheses so I can specify that it has
some number of items let's say 2 000 is
that enough letters for a song I think
it might work
so we'll use text
and then that's the last one we're going
to put so it looks to me like I have a
couple of extra columns here that I
didn't mean to do so let's go and select
the item that was accidentally put in
there I'm going to right click on it and
choose delete and then let's do the last
one as well and so now we're down to
just a few different columns here okay
so all of this here is I think correct
so I can close this tab and you can see
the changes occur here
now this is not quite finished we're
missing the link between these two
columns or between these two tables so
let's go look at these items here so
these are different links if I want to
have a relationship I can have a
one-to-one relationship or a one to many
here's another kind of one to one and
another kind of one to many a
many-to-many relationships so complex
relationships can be modeled here in my
SQL workbench
the one I'm looking for is this one that
says a it's got a dotted line on it now
I always do this backwards so I might
have to delete my links but I'm going to
try it anyway so I'm going to click once
here now I'm not holding the button down
I just clicked once I'm going to go
click a table so let's try this one and
then I can click this table
and it creates a link between them and
sure enough it's backwards so look at
the little marks at the end of the row
and this is this is why I know it's
backwards this says that on the side
here is a triple link it looks like a
bird's foot and the other side has a
single link so that means that for every
one track there are many albums so
that's backwards because the opposite is
true each album has many tracks and each
track belongs exactly to one album so I
messed up so I did that on purpose
actually because I wanted to show how to
delete it item because it's so oftenly
done incorrectly so I'm selecting the
line there and I'm pressing delete on
the keyboard oh I didn't work let's try
right click and choose delete then and
it says you want to delete this
relationship and I say delete
and it's gone let's try it the other way
so I'm going to click here again
this time I'm clicking on the track and
then back to the album
and as you can see now the relationship
is the opposite direction so we have a
single album matches with many tracks
and then here there's a new item it is
the uh it says at the bottom albums ID
so this is the foreign key the foreign
key says we're going to store a number
in the table that tells us which album
we belong to so each album has an ID
number and each track has an Associated
album to go with it
okay so that is our model
now we're going to try to synchronize
this to our database now when we do this
synchronization we're going to encounter
an error and I'm going to leave the
error on the screen because it's so
common and so we'll fix that up so the
first time we do this it will not work
but here's the attempt so if I want to
re-synchronize my database I click here
and I can choose two things I can choose
forward engineer which will erase my
current database and replace it with a
model on the screen or I can try
synchronize model now where is that so
synchronize down here so this is the one
that I prefer so let's try synchronize
now we're going to see the same choices
here we have a server number and then a
password so we have not updated the
database yet this is the process of
changing the model in our database
let's see click next
now I'm not going to do any of these
checks here so click next again
it says make sure that you connect so I
type in the word root for my password
click ok
says that was correct let's go to next
again
now it says which database are you
trying to synchronize and so I am using
music too
let's click next again
and it says it's connected let's click
next
and now you can see a preview of what's
going to change
so the albums and tracks tables are
currently in the design that I just drew
we're going to synchronize it with the
database which has a existing albums
table
and then the second item is a new table
so when I select one of these you can
see that there is a a statement below
so this is the SQL statement that is
going to be executed if you wanted to
use the command prompt and type all of
this out you could you'd have to know
every single type of exception and
option to be able to type this correctly
which is why I always use MySQL
workbench because honestly I can't
remember all of these things very well
so this isn't going to work but we're
going to try it anyway so let's click
next
and it gives us the preview so preview
the changes so it's going to say I'm
going to create a table the table is
going to be called tracks it's going to
be in the music 2 database it's going to
have all of these columns and then it's
going to have some primary Keys going on
here and this problem right here the
word visible is going to cause our
problem to Halt it's not going to work
I'll show you why so let's execute
log in
and you can see we have a problem so
this is so common people Google this all
the time to find out
why can't I synchronize it doesn't tell
me why it just says there's a problem
and here's what the problem is so we're
going to close this so the
synchronization failed here's what the
problem is we have a version number here
so if I go to edit
and preferences
and then I select the modeling MySQL
we're going to have a version number so
this tool is set up to synchronize with
mySQL eight dot something eight zero two
eight now if you already have version 8
on your computer then you didn't receive
any errors but more than likely you have
an older version like I do so let's go
and check out mamp and see what version
we're running
so I click here choose map
preferences
and let's go to server does it tell us
here it does so our database server is
running version five seven two four
so you can see the difference now
version 8 version 5.
it doesn't work so I have to tell my SQL
workbench that this is the version I am
targeting five seven two four so I'm
going to come back to here
and type that in so I could probably
just type in 5.0 so I have to actually
set this to version five two perhaps I
just had an error when I tried 527 so
let's try 5.2 and now I'm ready to
synchronize the model so the two tables
are here and this eer diagram is on the
screen if for some reason you want to
save this diagram you can you can go to
file and save and if you lose it you can
bring it back anyway I'm going to go to
the synchronize now so let's choose
database
and let's try synchronize the model
and then we're going to log in and try
to see what happens so let's see put in
our password
I'm going to choose next making sure
that music 2 is selected next again
next again
previewing the settings here so if I
click here you're going to scroll down
and see the same thing except for this
index no longer has the word visible in
it that's the change between SQL MySQL 5
and MySQL 8 at least in this one case
so let's click next and let's preview it
if you want you can see all the commands
and then choose execute this time there
are no errors so I'm feeling better
about this let's go ahead and choose
close
so we have now a foreign key
now let's go back to our other tool this
is the my admin tool from PHP so I'm
going to collapse music and look at
music too
so let's go ahead and click this green
arrow or refresh the page either one and
let's see what comes up now so I open up
the schema called music2 and now I have
two items here I have albums
and that looks the same as it did before
no change but now I have tracks
so now I want to insert some items into
the tracks table so I'm going to pick
one of the albums that I've already
looked at and I'm choosing Abbey Road I
hope that Wikipedia has a list of the
songs here on Abby okay here's one so
come together is one of the songs so I'm
going to insert some data here into my
table so I'm going to copy come together
and then switch back into my my PHP
admin so I'm in the tracks table and I'm
going to choose insert
and the track title I'm going to paste
that in so come together is the name so
the number on this thing it's track
number one in the album and now I need a
video URL so the video URL that I'm
looking for is on YouTube of course so
let's let's play the the song here
and you can see that I've got the right
one so this is come together so I'm
going to just swipe the URL from the
command bar or the UF address bar here
at the top and choose copy
let's stop that and now I'm going to go
back and insert it here where it says
video URL so it's just a text string but
it will link us to a video so how nice
is that okay down here the lyrics Do I
have the lyrics
so I'm looking for the lyrics so I
Google it and sure enough here comes a
whole bunch of stuff so let's go ahead
and copy all of this words that Google
gives us
and let's try that okay so I'm going to
copy this
and paste it into the lyrics section so
now I have come together yeah as my
lyrics and then the finally we have a
foreign key so when I choose an album
number it's going to say I'm going to
force you into one of these albums so
you can see the bottom group here has
the number of the album listed first so
three in Abby wrote the top group is
reversed so Abby Road 3 is the order you
can pick either one of these and they'll
both work so I'm going to choose three
and choose go
now this insert command was successful
you can see that there was one row
inserted and then it gives me the SQL
statement that was done here so all of
this here is what I didn't have to type
it did it for me
but you can see the the statement and
how the work goes so it's insert into
the tracks table
it lists all of the column names and
then the values so you notice the null
value for ID is listed so that's Auto
increment the rest of the stuff is all
things that we just entered in the form
so come together one the URL and
everything else so that is how to insert
let's go ahead and browse the table and
you can see that we have one item come
together so here's your homework I I
need you to put in two or three
different
tracks for each of the albums in your
collection so use the same process that
I did go looking on Wikipedia or
wherever else you can find the resources
and especially make sure that you get
the video URL from something on YouTube
and then we're ready to go on to the
next step in the next part of the video
we're going to use table joins so we
created a foreign key and now the next
step is to select items using that
foreign key to be able to use in our
application so we're moving ahead and
you're getting smarter every day with
SQL see you in the next video
[Music]
foreign
hi welcome back to another tutorial in
our SQL database application in this
tutorial we're going to work with joins
so if you look at the table of contents
of all the things that we've learned
we're up to the end of Row 2 here so
table joins is the ability to take two
tables and put them together here's the
entire playlist of everything that we're
learning so make sure that you stick
around for the rest of it my name is
Chad sluter and I teach software
development at Grand Canyon University
so I'm welcoming you to come to class
with me in this virtual way so that you
can become a professional developer so
let's get started with this next section
so this is how the application is going
to look by the time we're done with this
video so you can see that if I click an
item up on the top section I have an
album title and then when I click it the
bottom table is refreshed so that it
includes the tracks so for instance the
help album has three tracks and it has
helped the the night before and then
Ticket to Ride so I can't play the video
yet there's going to be a video player
over here soon so this is where we're
going we're going to have a second table
of data that depends on the items that
are in the first table so on the first
section here we're going to add a few
items to our form so let's start with
the user interface design so the first
thing I need to do is add a label and
then another grid view so I'm just going
to drag in a label and then after I put
it there I'm going to give it a new name
so it's going to have the text as tracks
and then below that let's put in a new
data grid view class or a new object and
we'll resize it so that we leave some
space over on the right side because
we're going to put a video player there
eventually but not in this video but
coming up soon so that's the only
changes we have to make to the user
interface so that most of the work here
in this part is going to go in the code
where we fetch data so the part I want
to work on first is in the albums Dao so
let's just refresh our memory what
albums Dao has I'm going to select the
first item and collapse it and then the
second method and so we have search we
have ADD and we have get all so those
are the three things that we see here so
we're going to make another item here
that will fetch all of the tracks from
the database that match an album now if
you recall from the previous tutorial we
created this foreign key relationship so
that way we have tracks that have an
album ID number in their table so that's
how we're able to make this work
so I like to reuse code and then
manipulate it so I don't have to type so
much so I'm going to copy all of the
lines for the method for searching for
albums so let's select everything from
the top to the bottom
and I'm going to paste this new method
down at the bottom of the class
then I'd have I need to rename it so I
go back up to line 122 it looks like in
my file and I'm going to name this thing
as get track for album or get tracks for
album
and the parameter that we're going to
expect to be provided here is an integer
so we're going to get the album ID and
return a list of tracks so that'll be
similar to searching for a name but a
few changes so let's make those changes
now
so the first change we're going to make
is we're going to return a list of
tracks instead of a list of albums so I
replaced the word album with track and
you can see that the computer doesn't
know what a track is yet we haven't
defined that we've just made a database
full of tracks but we haven't given our
object to our application so usually
those two things go together so let's
make one so I'm going to go to the
suggestions so I hover over track and
shows potential items and it says here
generate track it says where would you
like to put that I'm going to select the
first item which is in a new file so I
select that and over here you can see
that track is now defined so it has no
properties we can put those in now but
that was just one way to make a new
class
so let's go put all the properties in
that are in our database so the first
property of the class is the ID number
which is an integer and then I'm going
to get the next suggestion which is a
string with a name so the name of the
track is our second property the third
property is going to be the number which
is the track number on the album which
is an integer and then we go on to the
video URL the video URL is a string and
then finally we have a lyrics
property which is also a string
so we Define all these things and now
we're able to create new instances of
tracks so let's go ahead and save this
and go back into the Dao class so I
switch back into Dao and you can see
that now track is defined so there is no
error on line 125. we're not going to do
any searching by name so I'm going to
delete this wild phrase now here's where
the main part is going to take effect so
we are going to erase this select
statement and change it with another one
so what I want to select then is every
all the columns so star from the tracks
table
and I'm going to have a where statement
where we have a match of the album ID to
some placeholder here so we'll call it
at album ID so let's double check to
make sure I got the right column name
here because I'm not quite sure that
album ID is what I actually chose so
let's go back into the MySQL admin and
take a look at tracks and you can see
that albums underscore ID over here is
the actual name so that's incorrectly
typed in my code
so let's correct it here and I'll say
albums underscore ID make sure that the
column name matches this property here
the next line down we have to Define
what the parameter is so it's at albums
ID is the placeholder that I used in the
previous line and then I have a
parameter called album ID now just to
prove that I got that right let's scroll
up just a few lines to see where that
comes from so that's coming from here on
line 122. so we're passing an integer in
which has to be valid so we're going to
get down to the for Loop now or the
while loop where we do the reading of
each line we're no longer reading albums
this is adapting to tracks now so let's
change the type from album a to be track
and we'll use T for a placeholder name
now we can erase all of the properties
that we used for album and replace them
so we'll go through the list of the
anything that's in the table first of
all it's the ID then it's the name then
it's the number then I believe it was
the URL for the video and then finally
the lyrics and so those are all properly
given to us with this nice type ahead
help from Visual Studio
the last item where we add something to
the list of return these is instead of a
we're going to change it to T because
we're changing tracks
now it looks like I'm done except I've
got a strange error at the bottom let's
see what that is all about it says here
we've got a problem it says you're
trying to return tracks and you were
promising albums so let's scroll up to
see at the top of the function to see
what's going on here so in this line
here on 122 the data type for the return
says album and that's supposed to be
tracks so I think that's everything we
need so this function here or this
method should be able to fetch all the
tracks given an album's ID number now we
can't test this out yet in the user
interface otherwise I would go and run
it now we need to add something else so
that way we can produce the proper
output
okay so let's start at the top now of
our form one program and look what we
did to set up the data grid View we had
to have something called a binding
source so let's create a binding source
for the second grid
so I'm going to name this thing as Trax
binding source and we'll just
instantiate a new instance of it
let's steal some other code so if you
looked at this button click we had a
data source from the get all albums and
then assigned it to The Binding source
so we're not going to go through all
that again I'm just going to borrow this
and modify it so let's copy here and
let's come down to the bottom now
whenever we click the grid we want to be
able to update the binding source for
the second grid so let's go ahead and
paste in some things that we had before
so instead of albums binding Source I'm
going to have it as tracks binding
source
and then you can see that albums Dao is
undefined inside of this function so
let's create a new instance of it now
so we got a new instance and then we're
going to redefine the function that
we're using just on the next line so the
function that we created earlier or the
method is called get tracks for album
and then inside the parentheses we need
a we need an album Number well we've
just clicked something on the grid
that's why we're in this function here
and we need to get something from the
click
so we have it right up here it's on row
45. this is telling me which row was
clicked so we'll just use that so what I
want to get out of the data grid is the
number or the ID number of the album so
I can get that by saying go to the data
grid View
get the rows tell me which row was
clicked
then I'm going to get column 0. so that
is cells bracket zero and then give me
the value of that
so that should be an integer because the
First Column tells me the ID of the
album
now you can see there's a problem here
it says I'm getting the value but it's
not guaranteed to be an integer so let's
come down to show potential fixes and
choose add explicit cast and so it puts
this little thing in the front here it
says make sure that this is an integer
and then we'll convert it into something
that we can use to look up by an integer
the next line down says instead of data
grid view two one let's change it to two
and instead of the album Source let's
change that to tracks so let's go track
tracks binding source
okay so that apparently is going to work
I'm going to cross my fingers and see
what happens okay I got the app up and
running I'm going to try loading the
albums and they show up here now I'm
going to click on help and you can see
that it went to the database and
selected three items so each of these
has a various numbers of tracks in them
so this shows us the track and all of
the properties that are there now we're
not quite done yet because I wanted to
show you what foreign keys can do when
it comes to joining tables okay so that
kind of takes us to the end of this part
where we're trying to put two tables on
the screen we didn't do exactly joins in
this lesson but we did use results from
two different tables so that kind of
gets you a one step further to the end
now take a look at what's coming up
we're going to do uml diagrams and a few
other things so stick around and we'll
keep learning SQL together
[Music]
thank you
hi and welcome back to another part for
our SQL database application in this
section we're going to continue on with
table joins so if you've been following
along we're here at the end of row two
of our contents so table joins is what
we're going to be working on you can see
that we still have four more subjects
that we're going to cover and by the
time you're done you'll be an expert
with working with SQL databases my name
is Chad sluter and I teach software
development at Grand Canyon University
and you're in the middle of a process of
learning how to write SQL applications
so let's take a quick overview of where
we're going to be by the end of this
video so what you see on the screen here
is the database of our songs and as you
can see when I click one of the album
titles the rows below show us the tracks
now this is different than the previous
lesson that we did you can see that the
track titles here include things like
the album title and it's listed three
times here for in this case the word
help and then you can see the others
show the same results so what we're
going to do is have custom headers for
this bottom table so you can see that
there's more table headers here than are
actually saved in the database so how
are we going to do that well it's
through the magic of join so the first
part of this tutorial is to work with
the my admin tool to create the joins
and then to be able to put them into the
application as you see it here so let's
get to the first part which is what is a
join so let's jump back into the tools
where we were designing two different
tables and connecting them with a
foreign key so look at this example here
so we have tracks as one table and
albums as the other table and this link
the foreign key shows us that these two
tables are related based on a number
that's saved in each of these columns so
the albums underscore ID value here on
the right always matches with one of the
numbers in the ID column of the albums
table that's the foreign key and we're
going to use it to create joints so I'm
going to jump now into the PHP my admin
page and you can see that I have the
tables for albums and tracks listed here
so we have contents in both tables so
there's actually values to be able to
search for now I'm selecting the tracks
table and then I'm going to the SQL Tab
and we're going to write a select
statement so let's click on the word
select and you can see that we have all
of the column names listed for our
suggestion and then it says here from
the tracks table let's choose the go
button and just check to see if it's
actually working and so it says we have
11 different items that have been
selected so now let's experiment with
changing this select statement into a
join so I'm going to select again and
then I'm going to put in something at
the very end so I'm going to get rid of
the where clause for a second and and
then I'm going to say join so there is a
join and I'm going to tell it the name
so the albums table
and then you have to say the word on so
after the word on then you put in the
name of the foreign key so if I type in
here albums ID and then you're going to
say equals albums and then you have dot
ID so that's telling it which items in
the table contain a foreign key and to
which one It's associated with so how
did I know to use those two well I have
have this diagram in my mind where I see
that albums underscore ID is supposed to
equal albums dot ID which is the item on
the left so it's always a good idea just
to check to see if you've written
everything this will not change this the
results here but I just want to make
sure I haven't caused an error so I'm
going to check retain the box and go and
sure enough I do have an error what's
let's see if we can understand it it
says down at the bottom it says column
ID in the list is ambiguous
now that's an ambiguous error I don't
know what you mean what that means is
that there are two tables here and both
of them have an ID column so if you look
at the at the diagram you can you can
see that right away so tracks ID and
albums ID are both called ID and when we
join tables it really wants us to be
very clear to say which table we're
talking about so let's do that let's
specify which table so let's scroll up
and the problem is occurring here where
it says select ID so it doesn't know
which table to get it from now because
we can select from both tables so let's
put in here the word albums that's the
name of the table and then dot ID
so that will be one selection we could
also say give me the tracks dot ID and
that is also valid let's do the Go
Button now and see what comes up
so now the results are are valid you can
see that it says ID and ID and we can't
really tell which one is which so this
is a case of being ambiguous it would be
easier for us to understand the results
if we didn't have just the word ID so
since it is kind of difficult to
distinguish the two I'm going to rename
them so I'll say select albums.id as and
then I'll put a new label and a good
name for this could be album ID and the
same goes with the track ID let's now
rename it as again using the keyword as
and we'll say
tracks.id as track ID now let's let's go
again and see what that does so
scrolling down I see the results and now
it is very clear to say I know that the
First Column is the album ID the second
column is the track ID that makes more
sense so the neat thing about joins is
that you can select columns from either
table now and they will show up in the
results so let's say I wanted to for
some some reason add the album title to
each row in the search results so I can
just put in there put in albums dot
album title so what does that do let's
choose go and let's see the results now
and you can see that album title now is
listed here so every row contains the
album title along with the rest of the
items for each track so we're selecting
tracks but we're adding the album title
as the search results now I'm going to
reduce the number of columns that we're
selecting because that's a lot so I'm
going to remove a few things so let's
get rid of the first item which was the
album ID let's get rid of the number and
I'm not sure what else I'm going to get
rid of but I'm going to delete several
of them to reduce it so that way when we
do the search results now I click go we
have a fairly narrow item so I have
track title track title video URL and
lyrics so those are the results from
this particular query now I'm going to
take this query and attempt to use it in
my application okay so now it's time to
take that SQL statement that was using a
join and we're going to bring it into
the application and see what
consequences that has so what I want to
do is in this form whenever we click an
album title I get the search results of
the tracks below so right now it just
shows a list of tracks which was working
but we've changed the SQL query so let's
see what that does so I'm going into the
data access object here and I'm going to
copy the part that says get tracks for
albums so let's select everybody all the
way to the last item and Ctrl C for a
copy and then paste it now I'm going to
make some changes here and so let's just
rename this one as get tracks using join
so right now as an identical piece of
code get tracks using join we're going
to have to change the SQL statement now
so the select statement comes from here
so we have this nice statement that does
join so before I take this one step
further I just want to add a where
statement I'm going to say where albums
ID and I'm going to put in something
like a three so it's a placeholder three
is a placeholder so let's uh let's try
that out choose go so the results are
that every item comes from album number
three which is Abby Road so that is the
results because I said give me id equals
three so let's take this as our example
I'm going to copy that so now let's jump
back into the code here and I'm going to
erase this select statement that was
there and paste over top of it the
newest version so we've got albums ID
equals three so the three isn't quite
what I want I want to have this
placeholder l album ID so that way
whatever we ask for will match the album
Number okay so we got a bunch of columns
that are selected and then we return a
track and then hopefully we return these
okay so now I'm going to come back into
the form one and I'm going to change
this code here so this method was get
tracks for album let's see what up there
is now let's try get tracks for album
using join that's the new method that I
created so so should work right I'm
selecting let's see what happens when I
run it and uh what surprises might await
me so I run the application I choose
load the albums and then I'm going to
select help and we got a problem
so you can see here that the track has
what five different properties and when
we did a select with a join statement
all of a sudden we're selecting like six
or seven column numbers so you can't
just say put these column numbers into
the properties of the track object
anymore they just don't match anymore we
can't we can't use this process as it's
written so I'm going to fundamentally
change what this method is supposed to
return so right now it says give me a
list of tracks that's what the return
value is on line 169. so what I want now
instead is a something called the J
object and let's see if we can do that
it's probably going to cause a problem
so I type in J object and sure enough it
says I have no idea what you're talking
about so A J object is something working
with Json text which is a very flexible
way to create objects and c-sharp
doesn't automatically know how to work
with Json you have to install a library
so let's go down to the package
installer it says Newton soft Json and
we'll install whatever it says is the
most current package and the error goes
away now let's check to see what was
installed so I'm going to right click
and choose manage nuget packages and
let's check to see yep sure enough we
got newtonsoft or newtownsoft and it's
installed here at version 1301 so now
instead of returning a bunch of tracks I
need a bunch of J objects so down here
in the reader area we're going to expect
to add a new item which is going to be
of type J object so you're going to see
what a j object is in a minute I'm going
to print it so you can actually see them
so for right now just let you know that
it's a very flexible object it's kind of
like making a track object or an album
object except it has a flexible number
of columns and properties so we're going
to create a new one it's kind of called
new track and then I'm going to add it
to my list of return items so it says
here you got a problem so new track is
not the right type so let's scroll up a
little bit
and I have a list of things called
tracks here and let's change that to J
object
and that way it will be compatible
okay so return these is a type J object
now okay so the errors go away we're not
quite done we need to get all of the
properties from each column name yet and
so that's what we're going to do here
okay I need to cut that out and put it
in the while loop
so we're going to make a new object and
then add it to the list
so for each column that I select or each
column that I read I'm going to put it
into this J object so I'm going to make
a for Loop and I'm going to say go from
4 I equals 0 to the the length or the
field count of the reader so the reader
read a row and it has a bunch of columns
in it and the property called field
count tells me exactly how many columns
there are so it's a flexible amount
now I want to add some rows or I want to
add some properties to my new track
object here so I'm going to say new
track dot add
now we need two things we need a
property name and a property value and
we can get those from the reader
the first is to get the reader's name
property for this thing so let's say
reader.getname at column I so I goes
from 0 to the number of columns and so
that will be a string
that will be the first half of the
property the second half is the value
so to get the value we have a similar
item we say
reader.getvalue at position I so that
means we have two parts to each column
we have its column name plus its
property value
all right so check all that out I think
we got the columns all correctly now so
this will be flexible for the number of
columns that we're reading and then
we're going to return it to our our
other app part of the application so
let's go to form one so now we come back
into our form one and let's see what
happens when I run this so now I click
on load albums and I get everybody and I
click on help and this time you can see
that the select statement is only
selecting a few rows so we have fewer
items across there but they're flexible
in numbers so if I change the columns
that I'm selecting the bottom table
should be flexible as well so let's test
out that theory so I'm going to come
back down to here and I'm going to for
whatever reason is I'm going to leave
out the lyrics so let's just delete
lyrics and we have one less column let's
run it and see if that is as responsive
as I promised that it would be so here
we go let's load the albums and we try
help again and sure enough the lyrics
column is gone so I just didn't need it
for this part of the application so you
can add more columns and subtract
columns to the magic of this Json object
so this is not only a lesson here and
running SQL but a little bit in C sharp
and how Json text is handled so json's
pretty common you can see that the
advantages that you're no longer tied to
the static number of columns in a thing
like this like the track or if we
created a custom class called a data
transfer object or dto which takes the
number of columns and into effect so
Json was invented to work with
JavaScript but all other languages
including C sharp have adopted it and
you can see the flexibility of it so
we've moved on to another section so
let's get to the bottom row now and
continue to learning about our SQL
applications we're going to talk about
uml diagrams and how they are used in
design that's coming up next
okay
hi welcome back to another piece of our
SQL application tutorial in this part of
the video we're going to pause on the
coding and talk about design so the
subject is
uml diagrams now most students of mine
would say that design is not the thing
that they would prefer to do but I force
you to do it because it turns you into
far more organized in your mindset and
your projects turn out on time and with
far fewer errors so it's good to invest
the time my name is shad sluter and I
teach software development at Grand
Canyon University so you can check out
my tutorials on
studycoding.org or you can subscribe to
my channel so the first thing I want to
show you is a uml diagram for our
current application so you're familiar
with our music app so this diagram shows
two classes that hold our data so you
can see on the left side we have an
albums class and the right side is a
track class so these are in the c-sharp
code this is not necessarily in the
database yet but they're very closely
related there's another diagram this is
called an ER diagram or an entity
resource diagram and this should look
familiar too because we built this
directly out of the MySQL workbench tool
and so you can see that there are two
tables joined by a foreign key now
you're supposed to see that these are
very closely related in this case so
this isn't always the case sometimes
Java classes or c-sharp classes have a
lot more methods and properties in them
so the the bottom line here where it
says method pretty much ignored because
we're just using these classes to hold
data so uml is on the left ER is on the
right now you'll also see that there are
some different connectors between the
classes so classes can be Associated
they can have aggregation and they can
have composition
so in the first case if we were to say a
bicycle is a class it could be
Associated to an owner so it doesn't
necessarily have to have an owner but it
could however in the second part we can
see that there is an essential piece so
if we were to design the bicycle class
so that it had more components such as
frame parts
these would be called composition
because the part itself is useless
without the parent or some kind of a
component that really has no purpose
apart from a bicycle now you could make
the argument that some things like a
wheel here at the bottom a wheel can
exist without the bicycle it's not very
useful but you can imagine it so it's
kind of a fine distinction when you talk
about composition and aggregation so in
the case of our application I chose to
use aggregation here in the uml diagram
you can see that a track is part of a
album and so the album has a property
called a list of tracks so you could
argue that tracks can't exist without an
album but you can release a single I
think so I chose aggregation to
represent this in the uml diagram now if
I started to ask for new features in
your app the first thing I would do is
to send you to the drawing board and I
would say let's add some comments and
before we even start coding I want you
to draw the picture of how we're going
to handle these and so we would add a
comments table to the database wouldn't
we and you can see that we would have a
foreign key so that each comment is
associated with a track
now the track can have multiple comets
so that's a one-to-many relationship so
that's what the tables would look like
if we were to make an ER diagram for a
comments part now in the design for the
application itself we would have an
Associated uml diagram and so you can
see almost the same thing happening here
in this case I used a little black
diamond to indicate that comments are a
composition relationship to their track
the reason I chose composition was
because if you were to delete a track
from the system the associated comments
would have nowhere to go and so a
comment should not exist apart from its
parent it should not exist apart from a
track
so on the left side you can see that the
relationship between a track and an
album is labeled as aggregation
that's because a track could exist apart
from an album however on the right side
I have labeled the comments and tracks
as a composition relationship because a
comment should not exist unless there is
an Associated track now let's add some
more features let's say if I were to add
users and artists to the tables so you
can see that now a comment is associated
not using a string for the username but
an entire class called user so the user
can have maybe a login screen could have
a password could have a bio I don't know
what you would put in a user class but
you can imagine all of the things that
go into a user same thing goes with the
artist over here so instead of just
using a string and saying that this
album belongs to the Beatles we could
say that the artist has multiple pieces
we could have a little biography on the
artist we could have a list of all
albums that the artist has and so your
your applications start to grow adding
new classes that are related to each
other so then associated with that would
be the database so the associated ER
diagram shows all of the tables and the
relationships and the foreign keys that
go with them now by the end of this
course I'm going to ask you to create
some challenge activities and those are
going to include things like comments so
keep this in mind because we're going to
see that soon in the next video I'm
going to show you how to do something
called compound queries which is really
two queries kind of combined into one
action so we'll do that next
[Music]
hi and welcome to another tutorial for
our SQL database application so in this
part of the tutorial we're going to go
to this section here called compound
queries so we're going to combine one
result with another and we're just going
to refactor some of the code that we
developed in earlier sections so here's
the design that I'm referring to so on
the left we have the uml and we have the
right which is an ER diagram so we're
going to be modifying our model here so
you can see about the last line in the
album properties is a list of tracks and
so that's what we're going to implement
here in this video
my name is Chad sluter and I teach
software development at Grand Canyon
University so welcome to class make sure
that you check out studycoding.org to
get the full playlist and other courses
as well I want you to come along and
become a software engineer just like
many of my students so just to be clear
the application that you see is going to
look the same so I got the same actions
going on here so when I select an album
I have the tracks appear in the second
table on the application form so we're
not changing the look we're just
changing the design so let's get started
in the code so the first place I want to
go is into the albums class and some
time ago I left a note here that said
we're going to later make a list of
tracks as part of the properties here so
that's what we're going to do right now
so I want to show that we have a list of
type track and we're going to use the
get and set properties and make it
public the next part we're going to
adopt here is the albums Dao so I've
collapsed all of the methods that are in
this class just so that we can get a
summary of what we've made so you can
see we have a method to get all the
albums to search for albums by title to
add an album and then we have two
different selectors at the bottom one is
getting the tracks for the album and
then the second item here was also for
getting tracks using a join statement so
joining meant that we could have a
flexible number of columns so we're
going to be modifying these the get all
albums method here and we're going to
use the get tracks for album as a kind
of a secondary helper so let's get into
the get all albums so you can see that
I'm inserting right below the place
where we just fetched a new album I'm
going to now add the tracks property to
this variable called a so a DOT tracks
equals and then I can go to another
method in this uh in this class here to
get those tracks so get tracks for album
is another helper method we're going to
use now the part that's missing here is
that it's expecting a number so let's
type in a and let's get at the let's see
I think it's the ID number yes it is so
if we provide the ID number for this
album we should be able to get all the
tracks and then add them to the list of
things that we're returning so that's a
small change here but it's going to
allow us to save all the tracks at the
same time we fetch the album now that
we've returned all the tracks as well as
the album we can modify what we do in
our form one so here we are in form one
I'm going to the very top and I'm going
to add one new item so I'm going to save
a global list of albums that we can
refer to after it's been fetched so
we'll make a list called albums now just
to prove to you that I can use this list
I'm going to Define it here in line 21
and I'm going to fetch all the albums
and assign it to this list and then and
the next step down let's assign the data
source for the control to the list so
it's an intermediate step which is kind
of a temporary placeholder but we can
fetch this again without going back to
the database and you'll see that in a
second now there is an important
difference though so the albums now
contain a property that includes the
list of all tracks so we don't have to
go back later and fetch those again
so the next section I want to work on is
down here in the data grid view click
and event item so when we click an event
in the current stage what we have right
here are several lines that go back to
the database to get the tracks and
that's where we're going to change the
main point of this lesson so right now
it is going to the database to get its
values and we're just now going to use
the list that we have stored in memory
so I have to know that on line 46 I know
which row number was clicked so that
also tells me which album was clicked so
let's use that to our advantage so I can
wipe out any reference to the database
now and it's uh next is to just get the
item that was clicked and so albums at
row clicked and that tells me which row
number of which album it is and I'll
just swipe the tracks from that list
it's already been saved there so I just
reference it so let's see if that works
I'm going to run the app now all right
here we go so I'm going to choose load
albums and let it fetch from the
database there's my list so let's go
ahead and click something like help and
see what we get so we can see that one
of the tracks is help and the other two
so Abby Road what does it contain it
shows come together and Here Comes the
Sun so we've got ourselves a list that
appears to work the same as it did
before but we've just refactored it now
one final word about doing compound
queries as you can see here in the
albums Dao I am referring to the
database twice so in the second time
when I go and get the tracks I am going
through another loop so the more times
you add a request inside of a request
your database response time will become
less and less so be careful how many
times you are calling references to
another table because you are growing
exponentially in the complexity of your
for Loops so if you select something in
a for Loop and then another thing inside
that for Loop you're going from squared
to cubed into quadrupled and the power
so you can really slow down your
database with these kinds of reactions
now there are ways to make this work
better including indexing or if you go
to a different structure altogether
instead of SQL you could work with maybe
a nosql database such as mongodb but
that's for another course and so we're
trying to learn SQL right now so we're
going to do some deletions from the
database and also I promised you that
we're going to have a video player so
maybe we'll sneak that in next time see
you soon
[Music]
hi and welcome back to another tutorial
for our SQL database application in this
tutorial we're going to learn how to use
the delete statement so this is the
contents of all of the items in the
course that we've looked at so far so
we're on the second to last item which
is deleting my name is Chad sluter and I
teach software development at Grand
Canyon University I'm glad you're here
in class and you too can become a
professional web developer you can find
all the courses that I teach at
studycoding.org so make sure you sign up
there and get a great career so let's
take a look at how we're going to finish
off this tutorial so this is the app as
we have it right now I'm going to select
something like Yellow Submarine and you
can see the new item that I have below
is now a button that says delete
selected so let's click there and I get
a results says one item was deleted
click OK and it blinks off now if I
choose Yellow Submarine again you can
see that the item is deleted so that's
what we're trying to do is delete a
track we'll say of deleting an album for
another part but we're trying to delete
tracks in this part so there are several
steps we're going to accomplish first of
all we're going to add a button to the
form then we're going to add an item to
the Dao and then when we're all done
there we should have our application
working so let's start here with the
form and I'm going to just drag a button
in so we're going to put a button in
right below the table and let's put the
text on the button to say delete
selected track now this isn't the most
fancy user interface you've ever seen
but I remember our Focus here is about
building a SQL database all right so we
got the uh button here so let's double
click it so now we need to get in this
event we need to get whatever was
selected in the table and then call a
delete command so I'm going to scroll up
here and I'm going to grab some code
that will come in useful here what I
want to do is make sure that I have the
number that is selected in the grid so
this here this row clicked is the value
that I'm going to use so I'm going to
copy that and let's bring it down to our
last item so I want to make sure that
the datavid grid view I think it's
number two gets the item so let's uh
let's put in the grid two and then we're
going to uncomment the line just to see
if this is working let's test it out
all right we got the app and running
let's go ahead and choose load the
albums let's try help I believe there
are three items there so I'm gonna pick
the night before and choose delete
selected it says you clicked Row one so
let's try this guy and do it again and
this does seem to indicate that it's got
the row number correct now I don't want
the row number I want the ID number and
you can see that in my example 27 28 and
30 are the ID numbers that I'm
interested in so I have to fetch the
value from that column to be able to get
that value I'm going to go back up to
row 86 it looks like so there was a
statement here that says we're going to
get the row clicked and then get the
value out of one of the cells so I'll
copy him all right so let's go ahead and
paste that item into there and it says
here data grid view needs to have a more
specific name let's try number two
and I'm going to save this as an integer
and instead of video URL let's call this
thing track ID
now I've got almost everything there
don't I no this is a string this needs
to get out of the way
and I want to have the cells at column
0. so all of that now tells me to fetch
the ID number out of the grid we still
have a problem though we have an
underline and let's check to see what it
says it says here you're trying to
convert something called an object to an
integer so what that means is there's no
guarantee that column 0 has the integers
in it there might be an integer there if
I saved it in the database as an integer
so I'm going to assume that it's there
and what I need to do then is tell it
we're going to cast that whatever comes
out of that row and put it into an
integer type so there's a potential for
a issue that the app could crash because
well the database might not have
actually an integer there but remember
this is trying to make this as fast as
possible no error checking really going
on now I've got this integer here let's
see if it actually is an integer we'll
put a message box in just to confirm
that that's actually what we're getting
I'm going to put in a message box that
says ID of track equals and then we're
going to put in the track ID value Let's
test that out once again the app's
running let's go ahead and choose an
album and then after I have the album
I'm going to pick something so let's
select somebody like Ticket to Ride and
then click the delete button it says you
are on row two clicked OK and it says
track ID is 30 which seems to indicate
correct
so now it's time to advance where we can
take that id30 and ask the database to
delete that value delete that track
number
so in the next row down I'm going to
call upon our Dao and we're going to
call a delete method so let's make an
instance of the Dio and then we're going
to make a new call to it that doesn't
exist yet I want to save the results of
that as an integer and I'm just going to
call it result because I think it's the
number of rows deleted but I'm not sure
I'll test it out so I'm just going to
call it result I'm going to be equal to
the Dao Dot and I'll invent a new method
called delete track and provide it with
the ID number of the track
so now that we're done with that you're
going to see that there's an underline
not quite finished yet but we do need to
confirm something happened so let's put
another message box in to say the result
so what I'm going to do with this delete
track it doesn't exist as you can see so
if I hover over the error you're going
to say there is no method found there so
let's ask for it to generate a result
for us
so when I click that link it should go
into the other class and create that
method for us it's probably not
implemented but at least it's there
let's go see what happens so I'm going
to go over to the albums Dao and open it
up
and you can see that I have the previous
methods here I have get search ad and
here it is delete track so this is brand
new it returns an integer and it accepts
something called the track ID we're on
the right track now let's see if we can
add the code to make this happen so
let's go to the previous method which
was adding a new album so we're going to
copy most of the code in there and then
insert it into our current method which
is for deleting we'll make some
modifications obviously and then we'll
make the SQL statement work all right
I'm going to go through here and clean
things up so first of all the statement
where it says we are going to do the
insert that obviously is wrong so I'm
going to just delete that for now
and then I'm going to have one parameter
instead of four or five of them so I'll
delete all those
we're going to say instead of new rows
I'm going to call that a result and then
when I'm done I'm going to return the
result
so what do we have to do now we have to
add a SQL statement to make this happen
and after the SQL statement we're going
to have to modify the parameter that's
going to be used which is probably
called track ID so we'll use an at track
ID for the placeholder now the only
thing left here is to go figure out the
SQL statement and we're going to get
some help from the other part of our
program then my admin tool so now I'm
looking at the table here for the tracks
I'm a PHP my admin again I'm going to
come down to the very last item where it
says uh Yellow Submarine so I'm going to
select Yellow Submarine and then the
delete option here at the bottom
and it says here I'm going to execute
this statement so this here is the exact
code that I need so I'm going to right
click on that and copy whatever was in
there now just to test it out I'm going
to choose yes and it looks to me like it
worked it says Yellow Submarine is gone
so I got that code now I can switch back
into my application and right between
the little quotation marks I'm going to
paste it so here is the code so how do
you do a SQL delete well here's the
answer we do delete from and then it has
the table name then you have a where
statement where the tracks ID equals
something so this 43 worked for one
instance now I'm going to change that to
be a track ID as a placeholder and then
I'm going to associate that placeholder
value with what was passed in here so
this should all work hopefully now
remember all these back ticks are kind
of optional I'm just going to leave them
in for now because that's what my sequel
seems to like down at the bottom what do
we got here we got one more error return
return how about how about if we change
that to result that might make more
sense okay so we're going to execute
this delete statement we're going to
capture the results and send it back and
hopefully we get a delete
now I just deleted the Yellow Submarine
and I want to put him back so I'm just
going to come back and do a SQL
statement
and uh I have this prepared where it's
uh inserting a new item so I'm going to
go
and it looks to me like it put it back
in now we're at row 44. so you might
have to recreate a track if you've
deleted them all right it's time to run
this let's go ahead and click the green
button for our app and let's see if we
can do a delete all right here we go I'm
going to load the albums
and I'm going to try Yellow Submarine
again so let's go down to Yellow
Submarine there he is so I've got it
selected choose delete this it says you
clicked row zero it was id44
and the result was one so it must be one
row deleted
now let's see where did it go did it go
away let's try Yellow Submarine again
let's try it again and delete it
says 0 id44
this time the result was zero so you can
see that my user interface is not quite
updating the second time I tried to
delete this it says there was nothing to
delete so I believe it was taken out of
the database but the application on the
screen the user interface didn't show
the results so let's make a quick tweak
so back here in form one I'm going to
make two changes first of all I'm going
to erase the data source for grid two so
it'll erase everything that's there from
the screen then I want to reload the
albums because one of the tracks has
been deleted and we need to refresh that
so we'll do another call to the database
to fetch everything
all right with those two steps we should
be able to see some results now I'm
going to put in another copy of Yellow
Submarine just so I can delete it so I'm
going to switch back and let's try the
SQL statement and let's see do I have
that copied somewhere
and so I've got this insert statement to
copy and then I'm going to choose go
so now we're up to track number 45.
let's see if we can delete that track so
switching back I'm going to run the
application this time and let's go and
try to delete Yellow Submarine so I'm
going to choose load everybody
and let's go down to one of my tracks
let's try Yellow Submarine and then I go
down to select the Yellow Submarine and
delete it it says 0 track 45 and the
result was one this time as you can see
it deleted the screen it emptied out the
tracks let's try Yellow Submarine and
this time it is empty so it looks like
the delete worked now in the next video
we're going to talk about more features
that I'm going to leave for you as a
challenge so that you can develop your
skills and make this app complete see
you soon
[Music]
thank you
hi and welcome back to another tutorial
for the sequel database application in
this video we're finally at the end and
I'm going to show you some of the new
features that you're going to do so
here's the table of contents of all of
the things and we are at the last item
which is called future features which
means you get to do them my name is shad
sluter and I've been your guide here
throughout the course I teach software
development at Grand Canyon University
if you'd like to get the full course on
databases or on web development or on
mobile go to my website at
studycoding.org and you can get a full
degree almost just online Okay so let's
talk about some of the unfinished
business now that is left in this
application you can see on the screen
here that I have completed a whole bunch
of things without the video being on
let's take a look at what they are and
I'm going to challenge you to do them
and if you can't I'll give you some
source code that you can look at and
learn from so what did we do you so what
I've done is I've added some features
such as edit so if I choose Yellow
Submarine and choose edit you can see
that the the form over here is filled in
so that way we can change things so
let's say if I want to change the year
from 68 to 69 you can see that the
update button shows that there was one
row updated and so the updated item
appears in the list let's take a look
down below here so if I choose help and
let's try editing help let's go to the
edit selected button and you can see
that we have the same thing down below
we can either add a new track or in this
case edit one let's say I want to change
this to track number 13 and I'm also
going to change the album so you can see
that they drop down what would happen if
this actually went with Abbey Road let's
click the update and it'll give me a
status message and then if I choose
Abbey Road you're going to see help now
appears in the wrong album well we
better change that back so that it's
going back to the help album
the other choice is the delete button so
if I wanted to get rid of somebody I
could just push the delete button and
away it goes now obviously there's some
more code that's involved here so let's
take a look behind the scenes to see how
this works I've repurposed the input
form so that it not only can add a new
album and I've put down here a new track
I also have the ability to update and
edit those things
so let's look in the Dao which is where
a lot of these SQL statements or that's
where all of the SQL statements are
stored so we've got some new features
here so you've got an update we've got
an ad what else is there there's a
delete there is an updated track and get
a new track so all of the operations the
entire crud operations which is create
update read and delete they all require
some special coding so those are going
to be found inside of the new methods
let's take a look at one of them so for
instance update track so when I do an
update track I'm expecting to get a
object for the new track
and then an updated item number let's
see what we do with those inside of this
method so here is the statement that's
the key part that says I'm going to run
a SQL statement which is updating so I
copied this directly out of the MySQL
admin tool and we're going to be able to
adapt it just like we did with the other
items in previous tutorials so we go
through here and we add all the
parameters and I get an updated rows
number which tells me how many rows were
changed and then return it same thing is
going to hold true here with the updated
album so I have two items I say give me
a new album give me the album ID that is
going to be changed and then when I go
through here I get the same idea so I'm
changing a bunch of albums so there's a
little bit more code that I'm going to
let you look at let's try editing a
selected so you're going to see here
that when we click that button it's
going to fill in a whole bunch of text
values with the properties of the item
that is being edited and then I'm using
a check box called editing to be able to
tell if the form should be used to
update an item or to create a brand new
one and so if it's an update then we're
going to set this property to true and
then set the label on the form to be the
item number or the of the track number
and so those are some tricks to making
form have two purposes so the best way
maybe now to learn is to look at the
source code for the project as it is and
of course I'll put that on the course at
studycoding.org so you can take a look
there so if you'd like to learn how to
build more sophisticated apps that are
more web-based instead of just forms
like this is that's probably where
you're going to get a real job jobs are
going to be probably full stack
developer and those kind of Target
keywords but I hope you get a job and if
you do I'd like you to let me know so
you can contact me on LinkedIn or at my
YouTube channel so it's been a great
experience with you I hope you learned a
lot we'll see you in the next course
foreign
[Music]